You guys got it. Okay. Wow. The kitchen is crackling this morning. It's an all new episode of the Will Arnett breakfast podcast. So get your turkey bacon ready because we're about to sizzle up some stuff. Hang on, hang on. We're doing smart lists. We're doing, we're still doing smart lists. Yeah. It's the only one. Okay. But we're, are we gonna get to the breakfast? No, you should have had breakfast already, dude. Okay. Um, all right. It's an all new smart list. So your mic's coming in from over the top today, huh? You're usually, uh, undermiked, aren't you? I'm using my 87, which is my broadcast mic. Oh yeah. Well, you have, it looks like
你们懂的。好吧。哇。今天厨房里滋滋作响。这是一个全新的威尔·阿奈特早餐播客节目。所以准备好你们的火鸡培根，因为我们要开始煎点好东西了。等一下，等一下。我们在做智能列表。我们在做，我们还在做智能列表。对。这是唯一的一个。好吧。但是我们要，我们要去吃早餐吗？不，你本该已经吃过早餐了，老兄。好吧。嗯，好的。这是一个全新的智能列表。所以你今天的话筒是从上面收音的，是吧？你通常，呃，话筒位置比较低，对吧？我用的是87，这是我的广播话筒。哦，是的。好吧，你看起来像
you have sweat coming off your, yeah. Will, are you nervous? I was running around. I am actually nervous, but I was also running around trying to get my mic fixed and I could not fix it and, um, and that caused all that sweat. How did you break your mic? Did you have a bad, uh, uh, peanut butter chocolate session? What's, uh, what's the name of the, oh, uh, you know what I would say about that joke? It's lazy. It was lazy. I'm just pissed off because I still don't have free Reese's. You threw around just a bunch of info, but it was, it was lazy. You didn't, you didn't put it together. No, I don't usually. Well, I'm not paid right. I tell you what, it's really well put together. It's a Reese's peanut
你身上在出汗，对吧。威尔，你紧张吗？我刚才到处跑来着。我其实挺紧张的，但我也到处跑来着，想把我的话筒修好，结果没修好，嗯，然后就出了这一身汗。你怎么把话筒弄坏的？你刚才吃了一顿糟糕的、呃、呃、花生酱巧克力吗？叫什么来着，哦，呃，你知道我对那个笑话有什么看法吗？太老套了。太老套了。我很生气，因为我到现在还没有免费的里兹花生酱杯。你抛出了一堆信息，但这太老套了。你没有，你没有把它们串起来。不，我通常不这样。好吧，我拿的薪酬不对。跟你说吧，这个组合真的很棒。它是一个里兹花生
butter cup. Are you sorry? I'm not sorry. He's the best. Wait, but Will, trying to fix your microphone whipped up all that sweat that's dripping from your face and your body. What's wrong? Usually one doesn't really sweat when you just plug stuff in. I had to run up, I had to run upstairs, get some players, get some things hot in here. I just took a sauna. Oh, that's why. But the air, you have air conditioning on, right? No, he's still sweating. I'm like, I worked out. I got, you know what I mean? Okay. Sean, did you exercise it all today? Were you, are you, were you helpful to your body? No, not at all. Nope. Well, I want to tell you a little story, something that happened to me and Scott. I want to hear
酱杯。你觉得抱歉吗？我才不抱歉呢。他是最棒的。等等，但是威尔，修理麦克风折腾出了你脸上和身上流淌的汗水。怎么了？通常插个东西不至于出这么多汗。我得跑上跑下，我得跑上楼，拿一些钳子，把这里弄得热火朝天。我刚刚蒸了个桑拿。哦，原来是这样。但是空气，你开着空调，对吧？不，他还在出汗。我感觉像，我锻炼过了。我有，你懂我的意思吗？好吧。肖恩，你今天锻炼了吗？你有，你有对你的身体好一点吗？完全没有。没有。好吧，我想跟你讲个小故事，我和斯科特之间发生的事。我想听
a story. I want to hear a story about you and Scott. Okay. Here we go. So it was a couple of weeks ago, Scotty and I had a dinner to go to and I walk out of the closet and I walk out of the closet and he says, he says, you're really going to wear that. I'm like, what's wrong with it? And he said, it's too matchy, matchy. We can't both wear the same color red shirt. It looks weird. And I was like, what do you mean this is dark green? He said, no, by the way, I haven't owned a red shirt since I was four. Oh, I have a red shirt and everybody. And I said, we can't wear the same. It's, I said mine is green. He said, no, it's red. And we just both looked at each other because we both knew that how color blind
一个故事。我想听一个关于你和斯科特的的故事。好吧。我们开始吧。那是几个星期前的事了，我和斯科蒂有个晚宴要去，我从衣帽间走出来，我从衣帽间走出来，他说，他说，你真打算穿那个吗？我说，它怎么了？他说，颜色太配了，太顺色了。我们不能都穿同一种红色的衬衫。看起来很怪。然后我说，你在说什么，这是深绿色的。他说，不，顺便说一句，我从四岁起就没穿过红衬衫。哦，我有一件红衬衫，每个人都。我说，我们不能穿一样的。这，我说我的是绿色的。他说，不，那是红色的。然后我们俩都看着对方，因为我们都知道我有多
I am. And I was like, Oh, and I just, and I switched shirts. But when I was younger, I worked at the gap, remember, and girls would come in and they want to put together outfits for their boyfriends. This is what reminded me of this. And I'd be all confident and they'd walk out with like a mustard yellow sweater and shit brown pants and like a bright red shirt. None of it matched. And the coworkers would be like, after the transaction was done, I'm like, Hey, are you okay? Cause that was, that looks terrible. And they were like, are you sure? I was like, yeah. Are you clowning our customers? Are you doing it to fuck with them? No, I was color blind. I was color blind. I didn't really admit it. And so I was putting
色盲。然后我说，哦，然后我，然后我换了件衬衫。但当我年轻的时候，我在盖普（Gap）工作过，记得吗，女孩们会进来，想为她们的男朋友搭配衣服。这就是让我想起这事的原因。然后我会表现得很有自信，她们就会拿着一件芥末黄的毛衣、屎棕色的裤子和一件亮红色的衬衫走出去。它们一点都不搭。然后同事们就会在交易完成后说，嘿，你还好吗？因为那，那看起来太糟糕了。然后她们就会说，你确定吗？我说，对啊。你在拿我们的顾客当小丑耍吗？你这么做是故意整他们吗？不，我是色盲。我是色盲。我当时没怎么承认。所以我在
together these outfits. I gotta start listening to what you're saying. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. I was surprised. I help, right? I should know that he's color blind. Well, it's gonna cut my questions. I'm super, super, super color blind. You would think that, uh, that, that the gap that would be like the first test they would give you probably security clearance. And then if you're color blind, you're color blind and what's the deal? You think that there's a cure in McDonald's food? Is that why? I don't understand. So much McDonald's all the time. Hey guys, I'm up for the challenge if that's what it takes, but she does not have a cure for dinner tonight. Not a sure. You are. But, um, but
搭配这些衣服。我得开始听你在说什么了。对。对，没错。我很惊讶。我有帮忙，对吧？我应该知道他是色盲的。好吧，这会打断我的问题。我超级、超级、超级色盲。你会觉得，呃，那个盖普，那可能是他们给你的第一个测试，可能需要安全许可。然后如果你是色盲，你就是色盲，那又怎样？你觉得麦当劳的食物里有解药吗？是这样吗？我不明白。怎么总吃那么多麦当劳。嘿，伙计们，如果这就是代价的话，我愿意接受挑战，但她今晚的晚餐可没有解药。没有解药。你确实是。但是，但是
it's so funny cause those girls, cause they didn't know like what looked good on their man. And I was like, I can take care of that. And I was putting the other these outfits that were so ugly. Uh, believe it. Yeah. I don't, I'm not a big, anyway. Um, what I do want to do though, if I can switch gears for a second, I want to get to our guests because I am really excited. You asked me before if I was nervous. Yes, I am nervous. Um, it's not why I'm sweating, but it would not be unusual for me to sweat thinking about, you know, having this person on our podcast. This is somebody that I have a great, great deal of for real, what we call for real skis admiration for. Um, I don't think anyone says that. People,
太搞笑了，因为那些女孩，因为她们不知道什么穿在她们的男人身上好看，然后我就说，我可以搞定这个。我就把这些丑得要命的衣服搭在了一起。呃，信不信由你。对。我不是一个很大，不管怎样。嗯，我真正想做的是，如果我可以换个话题的话，我想聊聊我们的嘉宾，因为我真的非常兴奋。你之前问我紧不紧张。是的，我很紧张。嗯，这不是我出汗的原因，但想到（你知道的）请这个人上我们的播客，我出汗也很正常。这是我非常、非常、非常由衷地——我们称之为由衷地——钦佩的人。我想没人会这么说。人们，
a lot of people, well, they're going to start saying it for real skis admiration. Yeah. Yeah. I know it makes it sound less important. But I'm really, really nervous. Uh, this person has been nominated, I think for seven Academy Awards. Now I'm sweating. Okay. Uh, received an Academy Award in, in 2009. I don't want to say what it's for because I don't want to give it away yet. Uh, could have received an Academy Award in my view, probably five more times for other roles. This is a guy who, uh, has consistently delivered. I don't, I can't even name his movies because you're going to immediately know who he was. Uh, the first time I actually met him was only a few years ago because his, his brother played
很多人，好吧，他们马上就要开始这么说了，由衷的钦佩。对。对。我知道这听起来没那么重要。但我真的、真的超级紧张。这个人曾获得过，我想是七次奥斯卡金牌提名。现在我开始出汗了。好吧。呃，在2009年获得过奥斯卡奖。我不想说是因为什么得的，因为我不想提前剧透。在我看来，他本可以因为其他角色再获得五次奥斯卡奖。这是一个，呃，一直以来表现都非常稳定的家伙。我甚至不能说出他的电影名字，因为你马上就会知道他是谁了。我第一次真正见到他其实也就是几年前，因为他的，他的哥哥扮演
my dad. So for a minute, he said that he was my, my fake uncle. Um, he's a guy who started working with his brother and his dad when he was super young. Uh, and he has never stopped and all he's done is really incredible, interesting stuff. It's none other than Mr. Jeff Bridges. Jeff Bridges. Damn. God, I was so close. Thanks for everything. Well, you guys, Jeff Bridges. What a pleasure. I dig all of you guys so much. Oh my gosh, Jeff, this is so cool to see you. This is wonderful. Listener. First of all, you should know that Jeff is sitting in one of the yummiest looking rooms I've ever seen. This is, this looks like a downstairs. Yeah. Uh, this looks like a basement. It's got a wood ceiling. It looks like a set. It
我的爸爸。所以有一会儿，他说他是我的，我的假叔叔。嗯，他是一个很小的时候就开始和他的哥哥还有爸爸一起工作的人；呃，他从来没有停下过脚步，他所做的一切都真的是不可思议、非常有趣。他不是别人，正是杰夫·布里吉斯先生。杰夫·布里吉斯。天哪。上帝啊，我猜得太近了。谢谢你所做的一切。各位，杰夫·布里吉斯。真是太荣幸了。我太喜欢你们所有人了。哦，天哪，杰夫，很高兴见到你。这太棒了。听众朋友们。首先，你们应该知道杰夫正坐在一个我见过的最舒服的房间里。这看起来像是一个楼下的。是啊。呃，这看起来像是一个地下室。它有木质的天花板。这看起来像个布景。它
looks like a set. No, well it is. You got it, Sean. This is the, the barn from the horror house of heaven's gate. Wait, what are you talking about? Are you being serious? To me, you know, the director, you know, they were going to burn this, the set down because the owner of the land didn't want it on his property and Mike said, anybody want it? And I raised my hand and we numbered the logs and we put it 400 miles south and set it up. And this is where I've lived with my wife for about 40 years in Montana. Yeah. No way. Way man. In Montana. Yeah. Oh my God. You know, you know, that's a film I've never seen. Heaven's Gate. Oh man. No, that, that was the famous sort of like that it did like the first big
看起来像个布景。不，好吧，确实是。你猜对了，肖恩。这是《天国之门》恐怖之家的那个谷仓。等等，你在说什么？你是认真的吗？对我来说，你知道，那个导演，你知道，他们打算把这个，把这个布景烧掉，因为土地的主人不想让它留在他的地产上，迈克就说，有人想要吗？然后我举手了，我们把原木编了号，把它运到400英里以南，然后把它搭起来。这就是我和我妻子在蒙大拿州生活了大约40年的地方。真的吗？真的，老弟。在蒙大拿州。是的。哦，天哪。你知道，你知道，那是部我从来没看过电影。《天国之门》。哦，天哪。不，那是那部著名的，可以说是
studio flop. But, but I've heard subsequently that it wasn't really wasn't that big of a flop. No, it's, well, it's kind of a masterpiece. Yeah. I mean, you know, it, it, you know, so much of your experience of seeing the movies is how you're pitched, you know, what your, your setup is when you go in. Yeah. And if you get these, you know, they had such terrible views, you know, one review was if they shaved Michael Chimino's head, they would find three sixes. He is the devil and he's making devil movies. Oh my God. It was just terrible. You know, there was such animosity between all the, the suits and the reporters and everything. But it's, it's a brilliant movie. I would check it out if I was you. I think you might
第一部遭遇惨败的大制片厂电影。但是，我后来听说其实并没有那么惨败。不，它是，嗯，它算是一部杰作。是的。我的意思是，你知道，你知道，你对看电影的很多体验取决于你是怎么被推销的，你知道，你进去时的基调是什么。是的。如果你看到这些，你知道，他们有那么糟糕的评价，你知道，其中一个评价是如果把迈克尔·西米诺的头剃光，你会发现三个六。他是魔鬼，他在拍魔鬼电影。哦，天哪。那真是太糟糕了。你知道，所有的，那些高管和记者之间有那么多的敌意。但是，这是一部极其出色的电影。如果我是你，我会去看看。我想你可能
be, it's a long sucker. You know, it's about four hours long. My wife, Sue, just had a wonderful photo shop. She was taking pictures all through it. And Vilmos Zygman, the cinematographer kind of took her under his wing and mentored her. And there was this beautiful photographic exhibit that she's got in Livingston, Montana. And we had the producer up and Joanne Corelli. And it was exciting. And you're, you're a great photographer, too. Correct? Yes. I feel like I've seen some really, really cool wide angle black and white shots of, I want to say, Fisher King. Or do you do it on every single movie? Just about every movie since Starman. Okay. Wow. And it's called a wide luxe camera. And it's a panning still camera.
会，这家伙可真够长的。你知道的，大约四个小时长。我的妻子苏刚刚举办了一个精彩的摄影展。她在整个拍摄过程中都在拍照，而摄影师维尔莫斯·日格蒙德有点像把她护在羽翼之下并指导了她。她还在蒙大拿州利文斯顿办了一个非常漂亮的摄影展。我们还把制片人请了上来，还有琼·科雷利。这太令人兴奋了。而且，你也是个伟大的摄影师，对吧？是的。我觉得我见过一些非常、非常酷的广角黑白照片，我想说是《渔王》里的？还是你每部电影都会拍？差不多是从《星际迷航》开始的每一部电影。好的。哇。那叫宽景（Wide-Luxe）相机。它是一个摇摄静物相机。
And if you go on my site, Jeffbridges.com, look at the photography. Yeah. Okay. That's a good plug. You'd like that. But then you've got a wrap gift for everybody. Every single film you do. It's very smart. Yeah. And it's putting those things together. You know, the editing is tough because you take roles and roles. Yeah. Have you ever had some scumbag studio executives say, Hey, hey, hey, hey, we can't have you taking a bunch of photographs on set. No, no, no. And the Thespos, you know, us actors, you know, I know what it's like, you know, to have a, any lens pointed at you that freaks you a little bit, you know, but you know, they, I haven't gotten any complaints. And I'll give them, I'll give them the camera
如果你去我的网站，Jeffbridges.com，看看摄影作品。是的。好吧。这是一个很好的宣传。你会喜欢那个。但随后你为每个人准备了一份杀青礼物。你拍的每一部电影都有。这非常聪明。是的。把这些东西组合在一起。你知道，剪辑很难，因为你要拍了一段又一段。是的。你有没有遇到过什么混蛋电影公司高管说，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，我们不能让你在片场拍那么多照片。不，不，不。还有那些演员（Thespos），你知道，我们这些演员，你知道，我知道那种感觉，你知道，任何镜头对着你都会让你有点抓狂，你知道，但你知道，他们，我没有收到任何抱怨。我会把它们，我会把相机给他们
and we'll, you know, jam a little bit. Right. Yeah. They get in the pictures, too. I'm so excited you're here. This is so cool. Hey, Jeff, so let me ask you a question. I want to kind of get into it for a second. So I took a picture with you. We'll remember our picture that I gaffed. Yeah. Our prom pose. Our prom pose was so good. Yeah. Yeah. At some point. Yeah. You have to show that to the guy. I know. I got to get that. I don't, where is that photo? I don't know where that is. Who took it? Yeah. It's so good. And Jeff sitting on my knee and, and we were both doing press for something and we were in New York and and he said, you're playing my brother Beau's son. So I'm kind of like your uncle, your
然后我们会，你知道，即兴玩一会儿。对。是的。他们也出现在照片里。我太高兴你能来了。这太酷了。嘿，杰夫，那我问你个问题。我想稍微深入一点。所以我跟你拍过一张照片。我们还记得我搞砸的那张照片吗。是的。我们的舞会姿势。我们的舞会姿势太棒了。对。对。在某个时候。是的。你得把那个给那家伙看。我知道。我得把它找出来。我不知道，那张照片在哪？我不知道那在哪。谁拍的？是的。太棒了。然后杰夫坐在我膝盖上，然后，我们俩都在为某事做宣传，我们在纽约，他说，你在扮演我哥哥博的儿子，所以我有点像你的叔叔，你的
fake uncle. And, uh, but, but I wanted to ask you about Beau, who I adore. Yeah. Yeah. And, and by the way, he played my dad on Will and Grace and he played your dad on Will and Grace. Oh, wow. I think he played my dad too. Um, in a, in a thing called Thanksgiving promise that is, of course, I think I was in that too. I think you were too. I don't think we worked together, but I think both his sons were in it as well. Yes. Um, wow. Wait, he's played all of our dad. So I have all of, I'm your uncle. So Uncle Jeff, so Uncle Jeff, Uncle Jeff, answer me this. So you, you and your brother Beau and your dad, um, Lloyd, starred in Seahunt together. And this is, I'm going to kind of say once again, uh, not unlike
假叔叔。然后，嗯，但我，但我想问你关于博的事，我很崇拜他。是的。是的。顺便说一句，他在《威尔和格蕾丝》里扮演过我爸爸，他在《威尔和格蕾丝》里扮演过你爸爸。哦，哇。我想他也扮演过我爸爸。嗯，在一个叫《感恩节的承诺》的节目里，当然，我想我也演过那个。我想你也演过。我觉得我们没有一起合作过，但我想他俩的儿子也都在里面。是的。哇。等等，他扮演过我们所有人的爸爸。所以我所有的，我是你的叔叔。所以杰夫叔叔，所以杰夫叔叔，杰夫叔叔，回答我这个。所以你，你和你的哥哥博还有你的爸爸，嗯，劳埃德，一起主演了《海猎人》。而且这个，我要说一次，
our friend Jason here, you started at a young age working in TV. How old were you, Jeff, when you started doing that, the Seahunt? Oh, it must have been eight or so. Wow. But I was, I was, my first movie, I was six months old. Oh my God. I heard you were a nightmare. Yeah. John Cromwell was shooting a movie and my parents were friends with him and they needed a little baby in the shot. And Gene Greer was the actress. And so my mom said, Oh, take my baby. But I was a rather happy little kid and, uh, I needed to cry in the, in the scene. So my mom said to Jane, Oh, just pinch him. And she did. And of course, no way. And now we cut 35 years later and I'm working with Jane and a movie called, uh, Against All Odds, which was a remake of her
跟我们的朋友杰森不太一样，你很小的时候就开始在电视里工作了。你多大了，杰夫，当你开始拍那个，《海猎人》的时候？哦，大概八岁左右吧。哇。但我是，我是，我拍第一部电影时只有六个月大。哦，天哪。我听说你是个小恶魔。是的。约翰·克伦威尔在拍一部电影，我父母和他是朋友，他们在镜头里需要一个小婴儿。而让·格里尔是女演员。于是我妈妈说，哦，用我的宝宝吧。但我其实是个挺快乐的小孩，呃，我在那个场景里需要哭。所以我妈妈对让说，哦，就捏他一下。她照做了。当然，绝对没有。现在快进35年，我正在和让合作一部电影，叫，呃，《Against All Odds》，那是翻拍自她的
great movie out of the past. And I'm, we have a scene together. I said, Jane, I can't get there. I'm having some problems achieving the emotion I need in this scene, but you just please pinch me. So it gave us a good chore. Do you have, how is, how is your, uh, how is your trick for crying? Everybody's got a different, a different technique for crying on cameras. Do you, do tears come easy to you? I don't think so, man. What do I do? I look at a photo of my dad. Oh, yeah. What do you do? I look at a photo of my dad. It's a long story. You do. And that does it. No, no, sorry. You finished the sentence. He looks at a photo of his dad coming home. That makes him cry. Because every time he hears tires squealing, it kind of triggers it too. Gosh, it's always a challenge.
伟大的电影《过去的阴影》。然后我，我们有一场对手戏。我说，让，我找不到感觉了。我在达到这场戏需要的感情时遇到了一些困难，但你能不能请再捏我一下。所以这给我们制造了一个好笑点。你有没有，你的，呃，你哭泣的诀窍是什么？每个人在镜头前哭泣都有不同的技巧。眼泪对你来说很容易流出来吗？我觉得不是，老弟。我怎么做？我看着我爸爸的照片。哦，是的。你呢？我看着我爸爸的照片。说来话长。你真的看。这就管用了。不，不，抱歉。你把话说完。他看着他爸爸回家的照片。这让他哭了。因为每次他听到轮胎摩擦地面的声音，也会触发这个。天哪，这总是一个挑战。
How about you guys? What do you, you know, Jason, I heard one time, I heard a really interesting when you were doing, this is true story. When you were doing this, I'm not setting myself up for the job. You were doing, you were doing a scene on, uh, office Christmas party and everybody was cracking up in the conference room, right? And everybody was going crazy and they're all cracking up and you were the only one and you had to keep it together and you're not, and Will Speck said to you, do you remember this? We talked about this about a year ago and he said, you, what are you, how are you not cracking up? Everybody's cracking up and you said, I just imagine all of them dying in terrible things happening to them. I also, yeah, I also like,
你们呢？你们，你知道的，杰森，我听说过一次，我听说过一个非常有趣的事，当你在拍这个的时候，这不是编的故事。当你在拍这个，我不是在给自己找麻烦。你当时在拍，你在拍《办公室圣诞派对》的一个场景，每个人都在会议室里笑翻了，对吧？每个人都疯了，他们都在狂笑，只有你一个人，你必须保持镇定，你没有，然后威尔·斯佩克对你说了什么，你还记得吗？我们大约一年前谈过这个，他说，你，你怎么没有笑得前仰后合？所有人都笑翻了，然后你说，我只是想象他们所有人都在痛苦中死去，有可怕的事情发生在他们身上。我还，对，我还觉得，
I was like, what a psycho. I do something similar to that when people get the giggle fits, you know, on a comedy or something. I, the only way I can keep a straight face is by just convincing myself that they are destroying the movie with their childish, soft morick humor. I get like real high and mighty and indignant internally at that circuit. What a blast. Yeah. Just, I just, I just find disgust in them. Oh, that's fun. It can be very funny for the other Thespos, man. Yeah, for the other Thespos. Where'd it go? Uh, Jeff, what's one of the, what's one of the relationships that you, um, cultivated on a, on a shoot that you now, that, that ended up in a lifelong friendship? Like, is there? Well, you know, our dream come true was doing Baker Boys with Bo. Oh, yeah. Can you
我觉得这真是个精神病。当大家在喜剧里忍不住咯咯笑的时候，我也会做类似的事。我能保持扑克脸的唯一方法，就是说服自己，他们幼稚、低级、滑稽的幽默正在毁掉这部电影。我内心会变得非常高傲、自命不凡、义愤填膺。太刺激了。是的。我就，我只是，我只是对他们感到厌恶。哦，这很有趣。对其他演员来说，这可能非常搞笑，老弟。是的，对其他演员来说。去哪了？呃，杰夫，你在片场培养的，让你至今仍保持终身友谊的关系，其中一个是怎样的？比如，有什么吗？嗯，你知道，我们的梦想成真就是和博一起拍《贝克兄弟》。哦，是的。你可以
imagine how much fun we had, man? I mean, yeah, you know, if it was, if it wasn't my brother, you know, you spend a lot of energy trying to figure out how do we create the illusion that we're brothers. No, you didn't have to mess with that. I still, I think about you every day when I'm driving on Sunset Boulevard, that incredible, uh, yeah. Against all odds, right? Against all odds. Oh, with Jimmy Woods. Oh man. That car, that car chase. Wasn't that great? Hasn't been beaten yet. That was an amazing thing. And it was right by my parents' house there on Sunset. We had every, all the traffic going east, locked off. Yeah. Right at rush hour, and there are all these people going home to the beach. And in the middle of the shot, we're going 90 miles an hour, you're
想象我们玩得有多开心，老弟？我是说，是的，你知道，如果不是我哥哥的话，你知道，你会花很多精力去想我们该如何创造我们是兄弟的假象。不，你不需要纠结这个。我至今依然，当我开着车行驶在日落大道上时，我每天都会想起你，那不可思议的，呃，是的。《Against All Odds》，对吧？《Against All Odds》。哦，和杰米·伍兹。天哪。那辆车，那场追车戏。难道不棒吗？至今无人超越。那是一件了不起的事。而且就在我父母位于日落大道的房子旁边。我们把所有往东开的车流都封锁了。是的。就在交通高峰期，所有这些人都要开车去海滩。在拍摄过程中，我们开着90英里每小时的车，你
in the middle of it. Oh no, let's not go to the beach. And they'd hang a Yui, you know, and get in the shot. Oh, it was frightening. You couldn't shut down Sunset through all those rich homes right now today. No way. Jeff, you did, there were a bunch of movies you did in a row that I mean, first of all, I feel like you've had like so many different kind of phases, you know what I mean? Like you started, you did all these things early on, and you made a lot of great movies and last picture show. And then you did, and then the 80s, you know, you did Against All Odds and a bunch of other, I mean, amazing Starman and all these other great movies. And then in the 90s, you did like a whole other, you had like, you keep on having these different phases and you made like
就在中间。哦不，我们别去海滩了。然后他们来了个急转弯（U形转弯），你知道的，进入了镜头。哦，太吓人了。你现在今天绝对不可能把日落大道穿过那些富人区的路段封锁。不可能。杰夫，你拍过，你连续拍过一堆电影，我的意思是，首先，我觉得你经历过非常多不同的阶段，你知道我的意思吗？就像你开始时那样，你早期做了所有这些事情，你拍了很多好电影，比如《最后一场电影》。然后你拍了，然后到了80年代，你知道，你拍了《Against All Odds》和一堆其他的，我的意思是，令人惊叹的《星际迷航》和所有这些其他的好电影。然后在90年代，你拍了像另一个，你有过完全不同的阶段，你不断有这些不同的阶段，你拍了像
Fearless, which I loved, which I thought was a really underrated movie. That changed. That's hard to watch. I can't watch that movie anymore. Your performance of a guy who is faced death and then now is living his life with this fearlessness because of that experience, that really spoke to me. It was really impactful to me. Your performance really, I really got it. I really connected with that. And then that was actually after you had done Fisher King. And in the same way, I really connected with what that character went through in that movie and your relationship with Robin was incredible. And it was Terry Gilliam directed, right? Yeah, man. Fisher King. Tell me a little bit about that. Well, as you're, you know, as you're
《无畏者》，我很喜欢，我觉得那是一部被严重低估的电影。那改变了。那很难看。我再也不能看那部电影了。你饰演的一个直面死亡、然后因为那次经历而带着这种无畏精神生活的人的表演，真的触动了我。它对我的影响真的很大。你的表演真的，我真的懂了。我真的和那个角色产生了共鸣。然后那其实是在你拍完《渔王》之后。同样地，我对那个角色在电影中经历的事情以及你和罗宾的关系产生了强烈的共鸣，这太不可思议了。而且是特瑞·吉列姆导演的，对吧？是的，老弟。《渔王》跟我讲讲那个吧。嗯，正如你，你知道，正如你
mentioning these different movies, they start to explode in my head. Fearless was Peter Weir, who was just incredible. Yeah, Peter Weir. The director. The plane crash was just so well done that I just, I can't, I can only watch it the once because he literally puts you on a plane that's falling from the sky for minutes and minutes and minutes. Yeah, that whole movie was, you know, but each one, they're like little lifetimes, aren't they? You know, one is like a little incarnation, you know, and sometimes you get to work with the same people again. You mentioned Terry Gilliam. Yeah. God, he was just so wild to work with and Robin, you know, another kind of director wouldn't have allowed Robin to do the kind of stuff that he would do.
提到这些不同的电影时，它们开始在我的脑海中爆炸。《无畏者》是彼得·威尔导演的，他简直不可思议。是的，彼得·威尔。那个导演。那场飞机失事拍得实在是太好了，以至于我只能看一次，因为他真的把你放进了一架从天上掉下来的飞机里，持续了整整几分钟、几分钟又几分钟。是的，整部电影都是，你知道的，但每一部，它们就像一个个小生命，不是吗？你知道，一个就像是一次小小的化身，你知道，有时你还能和同样的人再次合作。你提到了特瑞·吉列姆。是的。天哪，跟他合作简直太疯狂了，还有罗宾，你知道，换作另一个导演，是绝不会允许罗宾去做那种他会做的事情的。
But, you know, we'd be working, you know, 16-hour days and before o'clock in the morning, everybody's dragging ass. And then Robin would get up and he would start to jam on all of the cast and crew, you know. He would go on and on and bustin' chops, you know, and other director, you know, would say, okay, okay, Robin. But Terry would say, yeah, but what about him? You know, Terry would go on for 15, 20 minutes. Oh, yeah, this is fun what we're doing and we have the energy to complete the day. But Terry and I are still close. We FaceTime all the time and catch up with each other. And then we did a weird movie, probably the weirdest movie. I think, certainly the weirdest movie I've ever made. And I think it might be the weirdest movie Terry made called Tide Land. Oh, wow, never heard
但是，你知道，我们会工作，你知道，一天16个小时，而在早上四点之前，所有人都筋疲力尽。然后罗宾就会站起来，他会开始对所有的演员和剧组人员进行各种即兴发挥，你知道。他会滔滔不绝地开玩笑，损人，你知道，而换作其他导演，你知道，会说，好了，好了，罗宾。但特瑞会说，是啊，但他呢？你知道，特瑞会说上15、20分钟。哦，是的，我们做的事很有趣，我们有精力完成这一天的工作。但特瑞和我到现在还是很亲密。我们经常FaceTime，互通近况。然后我们拍了一部奇怪的电影，可能是我拍过的最奇怪的电影。我想，绝对是我拍过的最奇怪的电影，我想它也可能是特瑞拍过的最奇怪的电影，叫《潮汐荒原》。哦，哇，没听说
of it. I play a junkie rock star. And most of the movie I play a carcass just dead overdosed. But it's a very bizarre movie. And again, worth checking out. With all the time that you've spent on sets and all of this, all of these sort of families that you've that you've met and built and then said goodbye to, right? All these these these groups of crews and cast. How much and you and you're usually in a leadership position, such that you can affect the harmony, the ecosystem, the whole situation there. Is that is that some is that an important thing to you? You seem like the kind of guy where it would be and that you would enjoy sort of setting a tone on the set so that we can all enjoy our work experience that you strike me
过。我演一个瘾君子摇滚明星。电影里大部分时间我都演一具尸体，也就是因吸毒过量而死的人。但这是一部非常离奇的电影。同样，值得一看。你在片场度过了那么多时间，经历了所有这些，所有这些你曾遇到、建立然后又告别的家庭，对吧？所有这些剧组和演员群体。很大程度上，而且你通常处于领导地位，你可以影响那里的和谐、生态系统、整个局面。那是，那是对你很重要的事情吗？你看起来就是那种会觉得这很重要的人，而且你会享受在片场定下基调，这样我们大家都能享受我们的工作体验，你给我的感觉
as that kind of guy. You hit that's the most important thing. Yeah, I think. I mean, my dad, you know, you mentioned see how to, you know, working with him. I was eight, you know, a little kid and he would set me on his bed and teach me all the basics. You know, you know, don't, you know, don't just say your life, listen to what I'm saying and then make that, you know, have something to do with the way you talk about it. And I go out of the room now come back and do it differently. You know, he would do all that stuff. But the main thing I learned from him was his joy at work. And whenever he came on the set, that was just contagious. And I got to work with him as an adult twice with Francis Coppola and Tucker and blown away. And that was
就是那种人。你猜对了，那是最重要的事。是的，我想。我的意思是，我爸爸，你知道，你提到《海猎人》，你知道，跟他一起工作。我当时八岁，你知道，是个小孩，他会让我坐在他的床上，教我所有的基础知识。你知道，你知道，不要，你知道，不要只是说你的台词，听我在说什么，然后把那个，你知道，这跟你谈论它的方式联系起来。然后我走出房间，现在回来用不同的方式再做一次。你知道，他会做所有这些事情。但我从他身上学到的最主要的东西，是他在工作中的快乐。每当他来到片场，那种快乐就会感染所有人。我有幸作为成年人与他合作过两次，弗朗西斯·科波拉的《创造公司》（Tucker: The Man and His Dream），那真是
such a gas, man, to do that advanced pretending with my dad, you know, as an adult. We would jam so we had such fun advanced pretending. Yeah. Oh, but, but, you know, that joy thing, you know, because it makes you relax, right. And then all the best stuff can come out of that relaxation and you feel safe. And, you know, it's yeah. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Did you learn most of what you use today as an actor from watching your dad? Or did, or did you, did you study strictly, you know, I study a little bit of Bergoff in New York. But I didn't really learn much there's mainly on the job training, you know, I mean, just, and then, and Bo, you know, Bo, I don't know, this is a story I've told before,
太爽了，老弟，作为一个成年人跟我的爸爸进行那种高级的假装游戏。我们会即兴发挥，我们进行了那么有趣的假装游戏。是的。哦，但是，但是，你知道，那种快乐的事，你知道，因为它让你放松，对吧。然后所有最好的东西都可以从那种放松中流淌出来，你会感到安全。而且，你知道，这，是的。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。你作为演员今天所用到的大部分东西，都是从看你爸爸演戏中学来的吗？还是，还是说你，你曾严格地学习过，你知道，我在纽约学了一点伯格霍夫（Burgdorf）表演。但我其实没学到多少，主要还是在工作中学到的，你知道，我的意思是，就是，还有博，你知道，博，我不知道，这是一个我以前讲过的故事，
maybe you guys haven't heard of telling again, if you're like, yeah, please, you know, one of the tough things as an actor is I, you know, where am I going to get an audience to practice my stuff? You know, yeah. So Bo, he's about in his early 20s, I'm about, you know, 15, 16 years old. And Jeff, I got to tell you, you look terrible. For 15, for 15 years. Yeah, we're not the side text you after this interview. I didn't sleep well. So Bo rented a flatbed truck and we would get some scenes together. We were working on some, you know, holding Caulfield, you know, what, Catcher in the Rye scenes, you know, other scenes that he worked at because we were trying to get me an agent and so forth. We'd get this flatbed
也许你们没听过，如果你觉得，是的，请讲，你知道，作为演员最难的事情之一就是，我，我该去哪里找观众来练习我的东西呢？你知道，是的。所以博，他大概二十出头，我大概，你知道，15、16岁。杰夫，我得告诉你，你看起来真糟糕。15岁的时候。对，我们采访结束后给你发私信。我没睡好。所以博租了一辆平板卡车，我们凑了一些场景。我们在排练一些，你知道的，霍尔顿·考尔菲德，你知道，也就是《麦田里的守望者》的场景，你知道，他研究的其他场景，因为我们当时在努力帮我找个经纪人什么的。我们弄了这辆平板
truck and we'd pull into a supermarket. And our father taught us how to do stage fighting. And so he would stage a fake fight. Up in the flatbed? No, no, I mean, the parking lot, you know, and we'd get, you know, but it would get our, you know, we'd act the shit out of it and the crowd would come around and we'd say, no, it's a show. And we jump up in the back of the flatbed and we'd do our scenes until the cops came. And then we would try to improv the cops into our scene, which really pissed them off. No way. And then we'd say, okay, we're going, we're going and we'd get in the truck and go to the next supermarket and we'd play the supermarket man. That's hysterical. So that was all in and around Los Angeles? Yeah, yeah. And what made
卡车，然后把车开进了一家超市。我们的父亲教过我们如何进行舞台格斗。所以他会排练一场假打。在平板车上？不，不，我是说，在停车场，你知道，我们会，你知道，我们会把戏演得淋漓尽致，人群就会围过来，然后我们会说，不，这是一个表演。然后我们跳到平板车的后车厢里，开始演我们的场景，直到警察来。然后我们会试图把警察即兴发挥进我们的场景里，这真的把他们惹毛了。不会吧。然后我们会说，好吧，我们要走了，我们要走了，然后我们上卡车去下一家超市，我们在超市里演。太爆笑了。所以这些都是在洛杉矶及其周边发生的？是的，是的。是什么让你
you want to go, you know, to the farm life in Montana? Well, I did the movie up here with Clint Eastwood called Thunderbolt and Lightfoot. And I fell in love with Montana. You know, got me a Harley Davidson, you know, rolled around. Because it's the opposite. It's the absolute polar opposite of. Have you guys been to Montana at all? I have, yeah. I don't think I have now, but I hear it. Oh, it's sweet, man. It is sweet. Yeah. And then I made a movie called The Rancho Deluxe up here and that's where I met my wife. And then that's, yeah. What was she doing on the film? She was, they used to do brain surgery in this whole place. It's like a big, it's a hot spring and stuff called Chico. Chico hot spring. And she was working her
想要去蒙大拿过农场生活？嗯，我在这里和克林特·伊斯特伍德拍了一部电影叫《霹雳炮与飞毛腿》。我爱上了蒙大拿。你知道，给我买了一辆哈雷戴维森摩托车，你知道，到处骑。因为这里是完全相反的。这里是绝对的极端的对立面。你们去过蒙大拿吗？我去过，是的。我想我没去过，但我听说过。哦，这地方太棒了，老弟。太棒了。是的。然后我在这里拍了一部叫《Rancho Deluxe》的电影，也就是在那里我遇到了我的妻子。然后就是，是的。她在电影里做什么？她，他们以前在这个地方做脑部手术。这就像一个大温泉，叫奇科（Chico）。奇科温泉。她当时在做
way through college as a waitress or a maid. I don't know. She did all kinds of stuff. And I'm sitting in there. We're in the hot spring doing a scene with Sam Waterston and Harry Dean Stanton and Richard Bright. I can't take my eyes off this gorgeous girl, man. She's got two black eyes and a broken nose and she's just gorgeous. I cannot take my eyes off her. And so I finally get the, you know, the guest to ask her out. She says, no, no. I say, no. She goes, no, maybe small town, maybe I'll see you around. And I said, Oh, okay. Her prophecy proved true. And I think it was at the rap party I saw her and that we danced and you know, that was, you know, that was all through bro. Now this is again a story I've told many times. If you guys have heard it, try to act like
服务员或女佣来赚取大学学费。我不知道。她做过各种各样的事。我正坐在那里。我们在温泉里跟萨姆·沃斯特恩、哈里·迪恩·斯坦顿和理查德·布赖特拍一场戏。我无法把视线从这个绝美的女孩身上移开，老弟。她有两个黑眼圈，鼻子骨折了，但她就是美极了。我无法把视线从她身上移开。所以我终于鼓起勇气去约她。她说，不，不。我说，不。她说，不，也许小镇这么小，也许我们会再见面。然后我说，哦，好吧。她的预言成真了。我想那是在杀青派对上我看见了她，然后我们跳了舞，你知道，这就是，你知道，这一切都是通过。现在这又是一个我讲过很多次的故事。如果你们听过了，试着表现得像
you haven't heard it. We love it. We'll do some advanced pretend. So now we cut 30 years later. We're married. We've got all these kids. And I met my desk open in my mail and I opened this letter from the makeup man on that show, Rancho Deluxe. And he says, I'm going through my files and I found something that might interest you. You was two shots, two photographs of a local girl that you were asking out. So I have a photograph of the first words that I've ever spoke to my wife. Oh, wow. And would you go out with me? And she said, no. And I have that picture. Now, did he know? Did he know he was sending it to you? No, he had no idea. He was my wife. No, no, he had no idea. What a valuable thing. Oh man. Yeah, that's my prize possession. Whenever I
没听过一样。我们很喜欢。我们会做一些高级的假装。现在我们快进30年。我们结婚了。我们有了一堆孩子。我打开放在桌子上的邮件，我打开了那封来自《Rancho Deluxe》剧组化妆师的信。他说，我在整理档案时发现了一些你可能会感兴趣的东西。那是两张照片，两张你当时搭讪的当地女孩的照片。所以我拥有了我对妻子说的第一句话的照片。哦，哇。你会跟我出去吗？她说，不。我有那张照片。那么，他知道吗？他知道他是把这寄给你吗？不，他根本不知道。他是我的妻子。不，不，他完全不知道。多珍贵的东西啊。哦，老弟。是的，这是我的无价之宝。每当我
think we're not meant for each other. Any of that. How long you guys been married now? Going on 45. Wow. How many kids? You said you got a bunch of kids? Three kids. Yeah. How old do they know? Oh, they're like, you know, 40, 36, 34. You got any grandkids out of them yet? I got three grandkids. Bennett, Barbaco, went to school with my middle girl, Jesse. She just had a little baby, Leon, and then Gracie and Ben. I would imagine I'm going to be a real goofy granddad. I'm going to be very excited to watch those grandkids. Oh, you think you're going to be less grouchy than you are now? Definitely. How many kids you got? Jeff, I have two daughters, 15 and 10, and they're little angels. Oh man, two daughters. That's yet. So I got three girls.
觉得我们不适合彼此。任何这些。你们现在结婚多久了？快45年了。哇。几个孩子？你说你有一堆孩子？三个孩子。是的。他们现在多大了？哦，他们大约，你知道，40岁、36岁、34岁。你从他们那有孙辈了吗？我有三个孙辈。本尼，巴尔巴科，和我中间的女儿杰西一起上过学。她刚生了个小宝宝叫里昂，然后还有格蕾西和本。我猜我会是一个真正的滑稽爷爷。我很期待看到那些孙辈。哦，你觉得你会比现在少发点脾气吗？绝对的。你有几个孩子？杰夫，我有两个女儿，15岁和10岁，她们都是小天使。哦，天哪，两个女儿。那就这样吧。所以我三个女孩。
Did any of your kids go into the business? You know, unlike my dad and my mom, who really encouraged me to go into it all. I didn't do that. You know, I really dragged my feet about going into it, you know. I had so many other things that I wanted to do, and I resisted. But that's kind of my M.O. in life. I resist, resist until I can't do that anymore and get sucked in. But I didn't give it to my kids. I didn't present it to them early enough, but they've cued me. And I could say, oh, you got this. You could do this. Did you dissuade them at all from it? Because I know I do that with my girls. No, no, no. I didn't know. I wanted them to come from them, because my parents, like I said,
你的孩子里有人进入这个行业了吗？你知道的，不像我的爸爸妈妈，他们真的鼓励我进入这一行。我没有那样做。你知道，我真的在是否进入这一行这件事上拖拖拉拉。我有那么多其他想做的事情，我进行了抵抗。但这有点像我的人生模式。我抵抗，抵抗，直到我再也无法抵抗并被吸进去。但我没有把它传给我的孩子们。我没有过早地把这个展现在他们面前，但他们一直在关注我。我可以对他们说，哦，你懂这个。你可以做到这一点。你有稍微劝阻他们不要进入这行吗？因为我知道我对我的女儿们就会这样。不，不，不。我没有。我希望一切都顺其自然，因为我的父母，就像我说的，
I was carried on at six months old. They were shoving it down my throat. Who wants to do what their parents want you to do? I didn't want to do it. I had other things to do. Yeah, I'm kind of the same. I have like, I have three boys and my middle son, he's a really funny kid. But both his parents, my ex-wife and I, you know, we're both in sort of comedic actors or comedians or whatever. And so we're like, we're hesitant to actually like, push him into it. But at the same time, we kind of want to just leave it open to him. And if that's what he wants to do, we're not actively dissuading him. And then there's the whole thing about competing with your dad or your brother.
我六个月大的时候就被抱去拍戏了。他们把这硬塞给我。谁想做父母想让你做的事？我当时不想做。我还有别的事要做。是的，我差不多也是这样。我有三个男孩，我的二儿子，他是个非常搞笑的小孩。但他的父母双方，我的前妻和我，你知道，我们都是那种喜剧演员或者搞笑艺人什么的。所以我们，我们对真正把他推向这一行持犹豫态度。但与此同时，我们又想顺其自然，如果这就是他想做的，我们也不会积极劝阻他。然后还有整个与你爸爸或你哥哥竞争的问题。
No, exactly. Well, that's weird. Right. I mean, Jeff, I mean, think about it. Like, yeah, your dad, Lloyd, was an actor forever. Huge star. And huge star. And your brother too, man. I mean, that's an intense dynamic. It could be, anyway. The competition there or lack of it, was it, I dealt with that with my sister as well. And we were always just very kind of open and upfront about, we took it as a positive. Like, well, you know, listen, we've got extra things to talk about now at the dinner table, you know? Like, that's all. Was it ever an issue with you guys? I would imagine not. It was really, you know, it's like being on the same team, basically. Like you say,
不，完全是。好吧，这很怪。对吧。我是说，杰夫，我是说，想想看。就像，是的，你爸爸劳埃德是个一辈子的演员。超级巨星。而且还是超级巨星。还有你哥哥也是，老弟。我的意思是，那是一种激烈的动态关系。不管怎样，都可能是。那里的竞争，或者说缺乏竞争，是这样的吗？我跟我妹妹也处理过这种情况。我们总是非常坦诚和公开，我们把它当作一件积极的事情。就像，好吧，你知道，听着，我们现在在餐桌上有更多的话题可以聊了，你知道吗？就像，仅此而已。你们之间这曾经是个问题吗？我想应该不会吧。这真的，你知道，这就像在同一个团队里，基本上。就像你说的，
there's so much in common, so much great stuff that you can talk about, you know, that's not always like that in families. But I just didn't want to, you know, when we did Baker Boys, that was no competition. That was like just a gas, man. It was fun and working with my dad. So I don't know, you know, so much about what we worry about. It's fantasy. It doesn't happen, you know. I'm such a believer in that too. All the worst things never happened to me, never happened. Yeah, what's that quote? You know, what's his name? Samuel Clemens, you know, what's this, you know. Is that what he said? You know, who's the guy? You know, I can't wait. This is something I don't know if it's COVID or old age, but my memory, man.
有那么多共同点，有那么多棒极了的话题可以聊，你知道，家庭里并不总是这样的。但我只是不想，你知道，当我们拍《贝克兄弟》的时候，那没有竞争。那就像是一次纯粹的狂欢，老弟。那太有趣了，而且能跟我的爸爸一起工作。所以，我不知道，你知道，我们担心的很多事情。那都是幻想。它根本没有发生，你知道吗。我也极其坚信这一点。所有最糟糕的事情从来没有发生在我身上，从未发生过。是的，那句名言是什么？你知道，叫什么名字？塞缪尔·克莱门斯，你知道，这叫什么。是他说得吗？你知道，那是谁？你知道，我等不及了。这是一件我不知道是因为新冠还是因为年纪大了的事，但我的记忆力，老弟。
Yeah, no, it's me too. You guys have had COVID or no? No, you had a bad case of it, didn't you? But even before that, I reached, I reached for something in my head and it's just not there. Yeah. And then you try to, it's like trying to remember a dream. And the more you try to remember it, the further it slips away. And so now I just say, fuck it. I just, it'll come back to me in five or 10 minutes. Who wrote Tom Sawyer? Mark Twain. Samuel Clemens. Thank you, man. Mark Twain said something about that. You're what you were saying. Well, you know, we worry about all this stuff and it's all just so painful and it's all
是的，不，我也是。你们得过新冠吗？没有。你得过挺严重的一次，对吧？但甚至在那之前，我在脑子里搜索某个东西，它就是不在那儿。是的。然后你试着去想，这就像试着去回忆一个梦。你越想回忆它，它就溜得越远。所以现在我只想，去他的吧。我只是，它会在五到十分钟内回到我的脑海里。谁写了《汤姆·索亚历险记》？马克·吐温。塞缪尔·克莱门斯。谢谢你，老弟。马克·吐温对此说过些什么。你刚刚说的那样。好吧，你知道，我们为所有这些事情担心，而这一切都太痛苦了，而且这一切
not, it's unneeded. Jeff, I'm glad we're talking about this now because just to get real for a second, I, I've been going through a thing lately and I don't know if it's because of the world around us or what. And I've been kind of like bombed out and I'm by nature, these guys will attest to it. By nature, I'm a very optimistic person. Joyful. Joyful. And I wake up every day, our dear friend Robert Downey said a few times in the last couple of years, nobody wakes up in the morning happier to be themselves than you. He said to me, and it's true. I'm very happy and joyful. And I've been kind of bummed out, man. And I'm like, is it because I'm getting, I'm asking my uncle, Jeff, now, is it because I'm getting older? Am I going through? I don't know
都不是必需的。杰夫，我很高兴我们现在能聊这个，因为坦白讲，我，我最近一直在经历一些事情，我不知道是因为我们周围的世界还是别的什么原因。我最近一直有点崩溃，而我生性——这些家伙可以作证——我生性是一个非常乐观的人。充满喜悦。充满喜悦。我每天醒来，我们的好朋友小罗伯特·唐尼在过去几年里说过好几次，没有人早上醒来会比你更高兴做自己了。他对我说过，这确实如此。我非常快乐和喜悦。而我最近有点沮丧，老弟。我在想，是因为我老了吗？我在经历，我现在要问我的叔叔杰夫了，是因为我变老了吗？我是在经历吗？我不知道
what's going on, but why am I, I have a sense of unwee right now. Yeah. But look at Jeff. Jeff's the most joyful guy we've had on the show. I know, but he maybe he's gone through phases. Oh, I go through phases, man. The emotional weather shit. Now, I wake up in the morning. My mornings are terrible. So challenging, man. Oh, I forget if I go, oh, another day. Really? I gotta do it all over again. I gotta do this. I do these little exercises that literally take only five minutes. You guys might want to check it out, especially if you got any back problems called foundation training. And it's about two, three minutes, but it's painful and it's torturous. And I say, I got to do that. Anyway, I got to have a couple of cups of coffee
发生了什么，为什么我，我这会儿心里有点隐隐的不安。是啊。但你看杰夫。杰夫是我们节目里最快乐的人了。我知道，但也许他经历过不同的阶段。哦，我经历过不同的阶段，老兄。情绪天气这破事。现在，我早上醒来。我的早晨糟糕透了。太有挑战性了，老兄。哦，我忘了，如果我去，哦，又一天。真的吗？我得把这一切重来一遍。我得做这个。我做这些只需花五分钟的小练习。你们可能想看看，尤其是如果有背部问题的话，叫做基础训练。大概两三分钟，但很痛苦，很折磨。我说，我得做那个。不管怎样，我得喝上几杯咖啡
and then I'm feeling good. But, you know, I think, well, it's the weather, right? Yeah. And then also these obstacles, you know, the difficulty, the challenges of where we are now, those are all opportunities to us to figure it out. Yeah. And also opportunities for us to kind of, you know, nash our teeth a little bit. Like the older you get, I think the more, the more you become aware of things that are just not great, you know, you just become smarter. Your radar becomes more acute and you can notice more things that could be better, you know? Yeah. And the thing that, you know, your guys' generation, what is it now? When I first heard this word, I said, are you kidding me? You know, the great career now is,
然后我就感觉状态不错。但是，你知道，我想，这就是天气，对吧？对。而且还有这些障碍，你知道，那些困难，我们现在处境的挑战，这些对我们来说都是找出解决办法的机会。对。同时也是让我们，你知道，稍微咬牙切齿一下的机会。就像你年纪越大，我觉得，你越会意识到那些其实不太好的事情，你知道，你只是变得更聪明了。你的雷达变得更敏锐了，你能注意到更多本可以更好的事情，你知道吗？对。还有那件，你知道的，你们这一代人，现在是什么？当我第一次听到这个词时，我说，你在开玩笑吧？你知道，现在伟大的职业是，
I want to be an influencer. Right. That's not us. And dammit, I want to be an influencer. I think that's, you know, and I guess we all are, you know. In one sense, I talked about this thing that Bucky Fuller, you know, the geodesic dome guy turned me on to. Trim tabbing, you know, he made this observation with the big ocean-going tankers, the challenge the engineers must have had with this to make a rudder big enough to turn this ship. And it took too much energy to make that rudder turn to turn the ship. So they came up with a simple, brilliant plan of putting a little rudder on the big rudder. Yeah. Well, the little rudder turns the big rudder and the big rudder turns the ship. And Bucky said, this is a perfect metaphor for how all of us individuals are connected
我想成为一个网红。没错。那可不是我们。该死的，我也想成为一个网红。我想那是，你知道的，我想我们所有人都是，你知道的。从某种意义上说，我谈到了巴基·富勒，你知道，那个测地穹顶的家伙启发我的事。微调片（Trim tab），你知道的，他通过那些远洋巨轮观察到了这一点，工程师们在设计一个足以转动这艘船的巨大舵时一定面临着挑战。要让那个舵转动以使船转向，需要消耗太多的能量。于是他们想出了一个简单而绝妙的计划，在巨轮的大舵上装一个小舵。对。好吧，小舵转动大舵，大舵转动船。巴基说，这是我们所有个体如何与
to society and our culture. We're all trim tabs. You guys, what you're doing here on the show, you know, this is all a trim tab and we're influencing. We're saying, hey guys, what about this? Check this out. Am I the big rudder or the small rudder? I love that. You're the small, you're the big rudder. And I'm turning you, Sean. I'm turning you. So listen, I will say, you've been influencing us and a lot of folks for a long time with all these great, great roles. And as Will was saying earlier, I love the way that you have bounced between back and forth between leading man and character actor just so effortlessly for so long. No one can do that. You tell me one leading man that can, you know, bite off a big, spicy, chewy character
社会和文化相连的完美隐喻。我们都是微调片。你们，你们在节目里做的事，你知道，这全都是一个微调片，我们在施加影响。我们在说，嘿，伙计们，这个怎么样？看看这个。我是大舵还是小舵？我太喜欢这个了。你是小的，你是大舵。而我在转动你，肖恩。我在转动你。所以听着，我得说，你用这些所有伟大、精彩的角色，长期以来一直对我们和许多人产生着影响。正如威尔刚才所说，我真的很喜欢你这么长时间以来，在男主角和性格演员之间如此轻松自如地来回切换的方式。没人能做到这一点。你告诉我哪个男主角能，你知道，啃下一个厚重、辛辣、耐人寻味的角色
and not look like he's chewing up the scenery. You know, you just, you got real chops, Jeff, and you always have. Thank you. Well, you know, a lot of that came from my dad because I saw how much he struggled doing sihan. He, you know, got that character so down that people thought he was a skin diver and they send him a bunch of skin diving scripts, you know, and he's a, you know, Shakespearean trained actor. You know, he replaced, let's see, here's a man I just forgot, man of La Mancha. Mark Twain. Anthony Quinn. Who is the famous, you know, I am I? Is that Anthony Quinn? Who is that? No, no, it's, but on Broadway, you know, he's, and he replaced him. And I remember doing a movie blown away, a movie I did with him. Sure. And I said to the producer, hey, I got a guy,
而又不会显得像是在浮夸地抢戏。你知道，你真的很有功底，杰夫，你一直都是。谢谢。好吧，你知道，这很大程度上来自于我父亲，因为我看到他在做《海汉》时挣扎了多久。他，你知道，把那个角色揣摩得如此透彻，以至于人们以为他是个潜水员，还给他寄了一堆潜水剧本，你知道，而他是一个，你知道，受过莎士比亚戏剧训练的演员。你知道，他替代了，让我想想，我刚忘了一个人，来自《拉曼查的男爵》。马克·吐温。安东尼·奎因。谁是那个著名的，你知道，我是我吗？那是安东尼·奎因吗？那是谁？不，不，是，但在百老汇，你知道，他是，他替代了那个人。我记得拍过一部电影《炸药庄园》，一部我和他一起拍的电影。当然。我对制片人说，嘿，我有个家伙，
I got a guy who could play my uncle. He kind of looks like me. He's a good actor. And he said, guys, I said, I said, Lloyd Bridges. And he laughed. And I said, why are you laughing? He says, well, your dad is a good actor, but he's more of a comedian, really. I said, what are you talking about? And it's because my dad did airplane. Oh, that's right. Which that, and so, and so he was labeled for a while as a, you know, he just does comedy. That's right. So I went out of my way to mix it up, you know, and do 180s as many times as I could early. I think that's really smart, man. I got a lot of, I did early on, people came to know me because of rest development. I think that people thought like, and I played a lot of characters who were, people used to say, oh, you
我有个能演我叔叔的家伙。他长得有点像我。他是个好演员。他说，伙计们，我说，我说，劳埃德·布里奇斯。他笑了。我说，你笑什么？他说，你爸爸是个好演员，但其实他更像个喜剧演员。我说，你在说什么呢？这是因为我爸爸演了《空前绝后满天飞》。哦，对。也就是那个，所以，所以他有一段时间被贴上了标签，认为他是个，你知道，他只会演喜剧。没错。所以我特地去尝试不同的风格，你知道的，尽可能多次地做180度大转弯。我觉得这真的很聪明，伙计。我有很多，我早期的时候，人们因为《发展受阻》认识了我。我觉得人们以为，而且我演了很多角色，人们以前常说，哦，你
play a lot of assholes. And I said, no, I don't play assholes. I play characters that are like, that have a lot of issues and that are unhinged, but they're not, I never see them as assholes. I always just see them as, you know, not connected to reality in some way, or they've got something going on. And like this character we did in the rest of it, he was like, his dad didn't love him, his mom didn't love him either. And then, you know, whatever. But I think that you get into that as an actor, I feel like for a lot of time, people are like, oh, you just kind of do this thing. And you're like, yeah, it's not really, since when, like, who gets to decide that I, that that's what I do now. I love it when comedians play bad guys. Like, you know,
演了很多混蛋。我说，不，我不演混蛋。我演的角色是那种，有很多问题而且精神错乱的，但我从不把他们看作混蛋。我总是把他们看作，你知道的，在某种程度上与现实脱节，或者他们身上发生了一些事情。就像我们在《发展受阻》里演的这个角色，他就像是，他爸爸不爱他，他妈妈也不爱他。然后，你知道，不管怎样。但我觉得作为演员你进入到那种状态，我觉得有很长一段时间，人们会觉得，哦，你就是在演这种东西。然后你会想，是的，其实不是，从什么时候开始，比如，谁来决定我，我现在的戏路就是这样的？我喜欢喜剧演员演坏人。就像，你知道，
remember Robin, when he did those two or three movies, back to back, we played the bad guy. One hour photo. And yeah, yeah. And then Albert Brooks played a bad guy. You guys have dark sides too that you can tap into. Yeah. Sean, Sean, take your hat off, Sean. Sean. Sean, you're dark side. I got crazy hair. That's kind of like a murderer's hair. Wait, Jeff, are you still doing music? Do you still play? Do you still sing? Yeah. Yeah. You know what I'm doing now is kind of fun. I'm going back into what I call my music mind and looking at, you know, a bunch of stuff that I kind of didn't, you know, have too much faith in and bringing those things out. And I said, oh, I dig this. This is pretty good. I'm jamming with my buddy T-Bomb Burnett to mentor me a bit
还记得罗宾吗，他连着拍了那两三部电影，我们演了坏人。一小时照片。还有，然后阿尔·伯克斯演了一个坏人。你们也有可以挖掘的黑暗面。对。肖恩，肖恩，把帽子摘了，肖恩。肖恩。肖恩，你的黑暗面。我有一头疯狂的头发。那有点像杀人犯的头发。等等，杰夫，你还在做音乐吗？你还在弹奏吗？你还在唱歌吗？对。对。你知道我现在在做的事挺有意思的。我回到了我所谓的音乐思维中，看着，你知道的，一堆我之前，你知道，没抱太大信心的东西，把它们拿出来。我说，哦，我挺喜欢这个。这相当不错。我和我的死党T·邦恩·伯内特一起即兴创作，他指导了我一下
and say, you know, what do you think about all this stuff? Shall I just make these little albums for myself? Because what's it, you know, I don't know. I don't know. I don't know what to do with it, but I'm having fun with it. I love music. I like his wife too. Oh, Kelly's so great. Yeah. Yeah. Really, really cool. If you could go back in time and see one concert from a band that's either no longer together or artists that are no longer with us, what would it be? I know mine would be Led Zeppelin. Oh, wow. Yeah. I was thinking of The Beatles. You know, you see Ronnie Howard's that movie and they played that last Shea Stadium thing with a good sound. Yeah. That concert would have been great, but I bet the sound was so bad that it wouldn't be that great.
然后说，你知道，你对所有这些怎么看？我是不是应该只为自己做这些小专辑？因为这是什么，你知道，我不知道。我不知道。我不知道该拿它怎么办，但我玩得很开心。我喜欢音乐。我也喜欢他的妻子。哦，凯莉太棒了。对。对。真的，真的很酷。如果你能回到过去，看一支已经解散的乐队或已经离我们而去的艺术家的演唱会，那会是什么？我知道我的会是齐柏林飞艇。哦，哇。对。我当时在想披头士。你知道，你看朗·霍华德的那部电影，他们带着好音响在谢伊体育场演了最后那场。对。那场演唱会一定很棒，但我敢说那音响太糟糕了，所以可能也没那么好。
But do you remember a thing called Rock and Roll Circus? Do you ever see that? No. Check that out. Google that. Rock and Roll Circus is something that the Rolling Stones, they hosted and it's just, you know, I think who is on there. I think John Lennon formed a band for it. It's a pretty wild little. Like an early music festival? It's an early music festival. Yeah, but it was like a circus vibe. All in a soundstage, I think. Yeah. It was something like that. Wow. Sean, what would you go see from That's Not No Longer With Us? Yeah. Maybe like the first. Oh, that's what you said, That's No Longer With Us. Well, yeah, like or just. Could be No Longer With Us or a band that's now defunct. Yeah. Well, I just got to say Ronnie Hawkins because Ronnie just bit the dust recently.
但你还记得有个叫《摇滚马戏团》的东西吗？你看过吗？没有。去看看那个。用谷歌搜一下。《摇滚马戏团》是滚石乐队主持的一个活动，它只是，你知道，我想里面有谁。我想约翰·列侬为此组建了一支乐队。这是一个相当疯狂的小节目。就像早期的音乐节？这是一个早期的音乐节。对，但它有一种马戏团的氛围。我想全是在一个摄影棚里拍的。对。差不多就是那样。哇。肖恩，你会想去看哪个已经离我们而去的乐队？对。也许就像第一个。哦，这就是你说的，已经离我们而去的。好吧，对，就像或者只是。可以是已经离我们而去的，或者现在已经解散的乐队。对。好吧，我得说罗农·霍金斯，因为罗农最近刚去见上帝了。
And I don't know if you guys know him, but he was quite an amazing cat. I would like to go see one of his early shows with the Hawks who were, you know, then became the band. I was, you know what I, Jeff, I was going to say, I wish I could go and see that Last Waltz concert. That's what I would have liked. That would have been a goodie. Yeah. I probably would have checked out the Carpenters. Is anybody still listening? Oh, yeah. Sorry I interrupted you, Sean. Carpenters, man. She had a beautiful voice, didn't she? Yes. Are you being facetious? I'm being both. I'm being both. You're being both. See, that's real brilliance, man. Because, because I was a huge fan. I was a massive fan. But you're also being a little bit cheeky.
我不知道你们认不认识他，但他是一个相当了不起的家伙。我想去看一场他和老鹰乐队（The Hawks）早期的演出，后来他们成了乐队（The Band）。我当时，你知道吗，杰夫，我本来想说，我希望我能去看看那场《最后的华尔兹》演唱会。那才是我想要的。那绝对是个好东西。对。我大概会去看看木匠乐队。还有人在听吗？哦，对。抱歉我打断了你，肖恩。木匠乐队，伙计。她的嗓音真美，不是吗？是的。你是认真的吗？我是既认真又开玩笑。我两者都是。你两者都是。看，这才是真正的才华，伙计。因为，因为我是个超级粉丝。我曾是个狂热粉丝。但你也有点调侃的意味。
No, no, but I never really. But you were a big fan of the Carpenters. I used to listen to them all the time. And Simon and Garfunkel. I would have listened to Simon and Garfunkel. All right. That I, I'd love to see that, that, that concert they did at Central Park. That would be fun to go. One of my favorite concerts I went to was a double bill with Paul Simon and Bob Dylan. Oh, Jesus. Wow. And Paul Simon comes out. These kips, you know, who, they switched who would open for the other guy. Yeah. Yeah. And Paul Simon comes out and he opens with something like America, you know, that, you know, and, and he's got two drummers, violin, horn section, you know. And I said, how is Bob gonna follow this, man? Yeah. And Bob comes out, he's got, you know, a bass, a drum,
不，不，但我从没有真正。但你曾是木匠乐队的超级粉丝。我以前经常听他们的歌。还有西蒙和加芬克尔。我会听西蒙和加芬克尔。好吧。那我会，我很想看那场他们在中央公园办的演唱会。去那一定很有趣。我去看过的最喜欢的演唱会之一是保罗·西蒙和鲍勃·迪伦的双拼演唱会。哦，天哪。哇。然后保罗·西蒙出场了。这些家伙，你知道，他们会轮流做暖场嘉宾。对。对。保罗·西蒙出场，他以诸如《美国》之类的歌曲开场，你知道，那种，而且他有两个鼓手、小提琴、管乐部，你知道。我说，鲍勃这要怎么接啊，伙计？对。然后鲍勃出场了，他只有，你知道，一把贝斯、一个鼓、
a piano and a guitar, you know. Yeah. And what does he open with? Hello, darkness, my old friend. All right. And again, Sean, you don't know if his tongue's in his cheek or not, man. He's just perfect. Hello, darkness. That's, that's my song, man. You got a Bob Dylan T-shirt on, don't you? Yeah. Look at that. Yeah. Oh, I'm a total fan, man. Oh, wow. I got to work with him in another weird movie that he wrote with Larry Charles. Do you know who Larry Charles is? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. What was the movie? So it's called Mask and Anonymous. Check it out, man. Look who's in it. Look who's in the thing, the cast that he's in. But it was Larry Charles and Bob Dylan wrote this over about three years. Dylan's the star of it. And Larry was his first thing he directed, man.
一架钢琴和一把吉他，你知道。对。他用什么开场？你好，黑暗，我的老朋友。好吧。又来了，肖恩，你根本不知道他是不是在开玩笑，伙计。他真是绝了。你好，黑暗。那，那是我的歌，伙计。你穿着一件鲍勃·迪伦的T恤，对吧？对。看看那个。对。哦，我是个彻头彻尾的粉丝，伙计。哦，哇。我有幸在另一部他与拉里·查尔斯共同编剧的奇怪电影里和他合作。你知道拉里·查尔斯是谁吗？对。对。对。是什么电影？所以它叫《面具和匿名》。去看看吧，伙计。看看里面都有谁。看看他所在的演员阵容里都有谁。但那是拉里·查尔斯和鲍勃·迪伦花了大约三年时间共同写的。迪伦是主演。那是拉里执导的第一部作品，伙计。
Wow. Wow. And it is a trip. Oh my God. I got to see that. What a cast. The albums I had on rotation, I was a kid, where I wrote them down, The Carpenters, The Eagles, The Cosby, you know, stand-up. Comedy album. Comedy record. Yeah. George Carlin's comedy album. Yeah. Yeah. And then, and Simon and Garfunkel. And, and, and Erasure Unplugged. Well, Erasure, everything. I know every word to every song. Oh, sorry. Fully plugged. Erasure, fully plugged. How about Nichols and May? Did you get into them? Nichols and May? Nichols and May, of course. Yeah. Of the doctor stuff. What was it? A little more gauze. I once, I once in the 90s went and saw, in New York, I saw within six days of each other, I saw Dylan at the supper club. They were shooting something and there was like 250 people there.
哇。哇。这真是一次奇幻的经历。天哪。我得去看看。真是个神仙阵容。我小时候经常循环播放的专辑，我都写下来了，木匠乐队、老鹰乐队、考斯比的，你知道，单口喜剧专辑。喜剧唱片。对。乔治·卡林的喜剧专辑。对。对。然后还有西蒙和加芬克尔。还有，还有，还有呆头呆脑不插电。好吧，呆头呆脑（Erasure），什么都听。我每首歌的歌词都倒背如流。哦，抱歉。完全插电。呆头呆脑，完全插电。尼科尔斯和梅呢？你们迷他们吗？尼科尔斯和梅？尼科尔斯和梅，当然。对。那些医生的段子。是什么来着？再多一点纱布。我曾经，我曾在90年代去过，在纽约，我在短短六天内看了，我先在夜总会看了迪伦的演出。他们当时在拍什么东西，现场大概有250个人。
And somehow I forget how I got in, but I got to see. And then six days later, I saw Jerry Garcia band and I saw them, within six days, I saw them both play Forever Young, which was really cool. Dylan and Jerry Garcia. And yeah, yeah. And they played together for a while too. Yeah, man. We'll be right back. And back to the show. Jeff, I want to ask you before we're done, I want, I want, I want to give you enough time to talk about The Cohen Brothers, if you, if you can. Yeah. Well, I was going to get to it. I want to talk about The Big Lebowski. This is a whole subject undoing itself. Yeah. Yeah. Jesus. But let's start. Can we start with Big Lebowski, man, how that came to you into your orbit and what that was like? Yeah, I can't remember exactly
不知怎么的，我忘了我是怎么进去的，但我看到了。然后六天后，我看了杰瑞·加西亚乐队，我看了他们在六天内都演唱了《永远年轻》，这真的很酷。迪伦和杰瑞·加西亚。而且，对，对。他们也曾一起演出过一段时间。对，伙计。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目。杰夫，在我们结束之前我想问你，我，我，我想给你足够的时间聊聊科恩兄弟，如果你，如果你愿意的话。对。好吧，我正要说到这儿。我想聊聊《谋杀绿脚趾》。这是一个正在自我展开的宏大主题。对。对。天哪。但我们先开始吧。我们能从《谋杀绿脚趾》开始吗，伙计，这部电影是怎么进入你的视角的，那是什么感觉？对，我记不太清了
when, but I ran into The Cohen Brothers, I think at a party or something, and they said, yeah, we're writing something for you, man. I said, Oh, great. Cause I had seen Blood Simple and I was, you know, thought they were terrific. And then that got the script. And I said, what? It's like, you know, a high school version of me that, you know, what, you know, what, you guys spying on me or something. And so that's how that happened. Well, how did they, but, but how did they, why did, so they wrote it specifically for you and that character like that? What was their answer to that? Why did you, I'm sure you had said, why did you think of me for this part? What, what had they seen? What did they thought? I don't know, man. And I said,
什么时候，但我碰到了科恩兄弟，我想是在一个派对上什么的，他们说，对了，我们正在为你写个剧本，伙计。我说，太棒了。因为我看过《血迷宫》，而且我，你知道，觉得他们太棒了。然后我就拿到了剧本。我说，什么？这就像是，你知道的，一个高中版的我，你知道，什么，你们是在监视我还是怎么的？事情就是这样发生的。好吧，那他们怎么会，但是，但是他们怎么会，为什么，所以他们是专门为你和那个角色写的？他们对此是怎么回答的？为什么你会，我确信你一定问过，为什么你们会考虑让我演这个角色？他们看到了什么？他们是怎么想的？我不知道，伙计。我说，
sure, you know, I, I, I, I got, I have kind of a history of trying to get out of parts, you know, when I'm with Terry Gilliam, I said, do you, why do you want me for this? I don't feel like this guy. I remember, you know, I pitched my other acting friends. What about this guy? And I probably did the same thing with those guys. I can't remember when I played just before it, but it was nothing like I had never played a part like that. Yeah. But do you remember, do you have a recollection though, Jeff, of doing that movie? Like when, when you're like, when it's like you and, and John Goodman and Taturo and, and Steve Buscemi and you're doing those scenes and you guys are all taking, you guys are all taking big swings with these, with these characters. Where you guys,
当然，你知道，我，我，我，我有一种试图推掉角色的习惯，你知道，当我和特瑞·吉列姆合作时，我说，你，你为什么想让我演这个？我觉得我不是这种人。我记得，你知道，我向其他演员朋友推销过。这个家伙怎么样？我可能对那些家伙也做过同样的事。我不记得我在拍它之前演的刚巧是什么了，但完全不同，我从来没有演过这样的角色。对。但你还记得吗，杰夫，你对拍那部电影还有印象吗？就像当，当你和，和约翰·古德曼、托图罗还有史蒂夫·布西密一起拍那些戏，你们所有人都在这些角色上做出了极大的突破。你们当时，
where you guys going like, Hey man, are we out on a limb over here? Are we good? We had such a good time, man. And when that movie came out, it wasn't, and it didn't do well here. No. It had this hit Europe first and then it came, splashed him back and really kind of well after the fact, but nobody really got it, you know. Right. I auditioned for them for, um, Intolerable Cruel Team. Remember that? And I went in and met with them and there were really cool, like at the 20 minutes that I got to meet with them and they asked me like, Hey, do you get, do you get stoned at all? Do you smoke pot? And I was like, um, like a little, a little at the time and they're like, okay, okay. Good to know. Thank you. Thank you for coming in.
你们当时是不是在想，嘿，伙计，我们这是在冒险吗？我们演得对吗？我们当时玩得太开心了，伙计。当那部电影上映时，它并没有，它在这里票房并不好。不。它先是在欧洲大获成功，然后才传回来，并且在上映后很久才真正火起来，但当时没人真的懂它，你知道的。没错。我曾为他们的电影去试镜，嗯，《残酷的意图》。还记得吗？我进去和他们见了面，他们人真的很好，大概20分钟的会面里，他们问我，嘿，你平时嗑药吗？你抽大麻吗？我当时就想，嗯，就，当时就一点点，一点点。然后他们说，好吧，好吧。知道了。谢谢你。谢谢你抽空过来。
And I was like, Oh, was that like the, was I supposed to say like all the time and then we could hang out? Well, they probably want you to score some of the weed for them. Maybe that's what you're holding. Yeah. Here's a weird thing, but I didn't, I was a podhead before I got sick and I can't smoke it, but I'm, you know, I consider myself a podhead, but I, I, and I'm kind of surprised that I didn't smoke one joint during that whole film. No way. No way. No way. Yeah. No, I figured, no, I read those lines, you know, and that good writing, it seems like improvisation, you know, but it's not. That's every man, every fuck, it was just well-placed. You didn't want to mess with that music, you know. I wonder how close, such a specific character, such a great
然后我就想，哦，我是不是应该说我一直都在抽，然后我们就可以一起鬼混了？好吧，他们大概是想让你帮他们搞点大麻吧。也许那就是你想表达的。对。这里有个奇怪的事，但我没有，我在生病之前是个瘾君子，现在我抽不了了，但我，你知道，我还是把自己当成瘾君子，而且，我有点惊讶，在整部电影拍摄期间我居然没抽过一根大麻烟。真的吗？不会吧？不会吧？对。不，我想，不，我读着那些台词，你知道，好的剧本读起来就像是即兴创作，你知道，但其实不是。那就是每个人，每一个他妈的词，都恰到好处。你可不想去乱改那些音乐，你知道的。我很好奇，这样一个如此具体的角色，你演绎得如此出色，
version of that, of that writing that you performed. I wonder how close it was to the idea they had for the dude. I wonder, well, they had a guy, you know, they had, Jeff Dowd was a guy that they kind of modeled the character after and I brother of Anne. No, I don't think so. It's a big world, Jason. Jesus Christ. It's fucking seven billion people on the planet, get wise motherfucker. Hey, you know, you know what, Jeff, you know, it's funny. We had Sean Pan on the show last year at some point and he talked about how he's good, isn't he? He's a good actor. He can do all this kind of thing. But he's like you. He's like you, man. He makes, he makes, he's just like you. You guys are cut from the same cloth, man. And he was talking about doing
那段剧本的呈现，离他们心目中“老dude”的想法究竟有多近？我想，好吧，他们有一个原型，你知道的，杰夫·多德（Jeff Dowd）就是他们塑造这个角色的原型，而我是安的兄弟。不，我不这么觉得。世界很大，杰逊。天哪。地球上有他妈七十亿人口，聪明点吧，混蛋。嘿，你知道，你知道吗，杰夫，说来有趣。我们去年某个时候邀请了肖恩·潘上节目，他谈到了他演得很好，对吧？他是个好演员。他能演各种各样的角色。但他就像你。他就像你，伙计。他做事的风格，你们俩真是同一类人，伙计。他当时在谈论扮演
Spicoli, his character from fast times. Oh yeah. And then recently running into the guy that he always had in mind who he based it on and the guy was with his kids and stuff. So he didn't say anything to the guy. He saw him like on the path to go surfing in Malibu. And the dude was like, hey, man, he's like, oh, hey, and he's like, oh, this is the guy I modeled this burnout character on. And now he's with his wife and kids who's like, I'm not going to say anything. Give or see, this must be the place, a movie that he was in that based on the David Byrne song, you know, the Talking Heads. Yeah, of course. David's in the movie too, but that's another good one, man. He plays kind of a burnout, you know, glam rocker or something. Oh, no, we had, we had David on the,
斯皮科利（Spicoli），他在《开放的美国学府》里的角色。哦，对。然后最近碰巧遇到了那个他一直记在心里、以此为原型的家伙，那个家伙当时正和他的孩子们在一起什么的。所以他什么也没跟那家伙说。他在去马里布冲浪的小路上看到了他。那家伙就像是，嘿，伙计，然后他就像是，哦，嘿，然后他就像是，哦，这就是我塑造这个垮掉派角色的原型。而现在他和他的妻子孩子在一起，就像是，我什么都不会说。或者你看，这是《因父之名》，他参演的一部电影，根据大卫·伯恩（David Byrne）的歌改编的，你知道，就是那个“说话脑袋”乐队（Talking Heads）。对，当然。大卫也参演了那部电影，但那是另一部好片，伙计。他演了一个有点垮掉的，你知道的，华丽摇滚乐手什么的。哦，不，我们邀请了戴维上，
on the podcast recently, actually. Oh, man, the Talking Heads. Now, when they came out, man, man, they replaced the Beatles for me. Oh, wow. And I remember I ran into David at some bar or something in New York, and I just, you know, I have a few drinks I went to. I just gush, I said, take it. Music, man. I mean, it's so incredible. You know, he's just, he said, no, man, I mean, like the Beatles, you're better than the Beatles, man. And he just did that. And he just, there was no answer. And I finally just had to walk away. By the way, I do that. I'm very passionate about music too. And I do that a lot too. Musicians, I corner them all the time. And like, what about his shows? What about that American
最近上了我们的播客，其实。哦，天哪，“说话脑袋”乐队。当他们出道时，伙计，伙计，他们取代了披头士在我心中的地位。哦，哇。我记得我在纽约的某个酒吧遇到了大卫，然后我就，你知道，我喝了几杯就走过去了。我简直是滔滔不绝，我说，听着。音乐，伙计。我的意思是，太不可思议了。你知道，他只是，他说，不，伙计，我的意思是，就像披头士，你比披头士还棒，伙计。然后他就那样。他就那样，什么都没回答。我最后只好走开了。顺便说一句，我就是这样。我对音乐也非常充满激情。我这也经常干。音乐人，我经常把他们堵在角落里。比如，他的演出怎么样？那场《美国乌托邦》怎么样？
Utopia? Yeah, that's incredible. I saw that live. That's incredible. And the movie's great too. And I also saw the Stop Making Sense tour at the Greek theater. Oh, wow. Oh, really? You've seen that movie? Well, of course, yeah. And he shot that here on a stage, that movie. Jonathan Demme, man. He shot that, God. He knows where to put it. I feel like you worked with Jonathan Demme, didn't you? No, I would love to have, but no. But he was wonderful, God. Amazing. I want to know, so the place where you're at right now is a farm. Is it actually a farm? So we call it a ranch. A ranch. And do you actually do work around there? Do you have like animals? We had, you know, we had a bunch of, you know, cattle and horses and all stuff.
对，那太不可思议了。我看过现场。那太不可思议了。那部电影也很棒。我还看过在希腊剧院的“停止制造”（Stop Making Sense）巡演。哦，哇。哦，真的吗？你看过那部电影？嗯，当然，对。他在那里的一个舞台上拍了那部电影。乔纳森·戴米（Jonathan Demme），伙计。他在那拍的，天哪。他太懂镜头该摆在哪了。我觉得你和乔纳森·戴米合作过，对吧？不，我本希望合作的，但没有。但他太棒了，天哪。惊人。我想知道，所以你现在住的地方是一个农场？真的是农场吗？所以我们叫它牧场。牧场。那你真的会在那里干农场活吗？你养了动物吗？我们有，你知道，我们有成群的，你知道，牛和马之类的东西。
We don't need more. You shot them. You just shot them all. You shot them buried. It was a slow Sunday. It's like, honey, we're going to do something fun. Let's see how many cows. You know, something I ask people that have had a ton of set experiences you have have. Have you ever been drawn to direct, to use all that you have absorbed and put it all in that role, that character? Yeah, a little bit, because I've been digging your direction in Ozark, man. I think, God, that must be fun, man. Oh, God. He writes it, directs it, acts so brilliantly. But you're very nice. But the stuff you have absorbed and from the directors that you've worked with and the actors. Yeah, but you know, and I've had great luck with first time
你们不需要更多了。你们把它们全枪毙了。你把它们全枪毙了。你开枪打死并埋了它们。那是一个慵懒的星期天。就像，亲爱的，我们要找点乐子。让我们看看能打死多少头牛。你知道，我常常会问那些有着你这样丰富片场经验的人一个问题。你有没有被吸引去当导演，去运用你所吸收的一切，然后把它们全部投入到那个角色中去？对，有一点，因为我很喜欢你在《黑钱胜地》里的导演风格，伙计。我想，天哪，那一定很有趣，伙计。哦，天哪。他自己编剧、自己导演、演技还如此精湛。不过你太客气了。但你吸收的东西，从你合作过的导演和演员那里学到的。对，但你知道的，我和新人导演合作运势一直很好，你知道，真的非常不可思议。我想到了《一曲相思情未了》的史蒂夫·克洛夫斯，你知道，他写剧本并执导那部电影时肯定才24岁。
directors, you know, really incredible. I'm thinking of Baker Boys, Steve Clovis, you know, he must have been 24 when he wrote and directed that. No way. And I've had just great, great experiences with these guys. And, you know, as an actor, you know, you, if you create this loosey-goosey, you know, joyous feeling, you're all given ideas. And so I get a lot of my wanting to direct out and just, you know, being on the team and say, Hey, what about this? You know, about that, that kind of thing. Yeah, I think that you say you've had a lot of luck with like first time directors and stuff. But I bet you, Jeff, I bet you spent your life making your own luck. And I bet you're coming with a good attitude. And I bet you that is fostered, you know, I bet you all those first
不会吧。我和这些家伙有过非常非常棒的合作经历。而且，你知道，作为一名演员，你知道，如果你营造出一种轻松随意、欢乐的气氛，大家都会提出各种点子。所以我通过融入团队，扮演好团队的一员，说“嘿，这个怎么样？”或者“那个怎么样？”，从而满足了我对导演的渴望，诸如此类。对，我觉得你说你和很多新人导演合作过，运气很好。但我敢说，杰夫，我敢说你这一生都在为自己创造运气。我敢说你带着良好的态度加入剧组，我敢说这培养了，我敢说所有那些新人导演能让他们的作品成型、能在电影里有你这样的主演，他们真的很走运。他妈的，是的。对，对，对。但那些新人导演，我的意思是，看看奥逊·威尔斯，我们在《公民凯恩》之后就没拍出过比它好多少的作品了，伙计。
time directors are lucky to have had you making their stuff work, be the guy in their movie. Fuck, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But those first time, I mean, look at Orison Wells, we haven't done much better than Citizen Kane, man. Right. And it was all that stuff that he didn't know what he couldn't do. He just said, let's jam, you know, and who's the famous DP, Greg Toland, you know. He was the old master. And there was a story that Peter Begdonovitch, who was a real, you know, scholar with movies, he told me a story because he was tight with Orison Wells. And, you know, Orison said, you know, I can't really get, you know, the stage direction, you know, that thing. And Toland said, oh, just come over on the weekend and we'll, you know, know, don't you love it
没错。而且所有那些东西，都是因为他不知道自己有哪些事是不能做的。他只是说，我们来即兴创作吧，你知道，还有那个著名的摄影指导格雷格·托兰德（Greg Toland），你知道。他是老大师。有个故事是彼得·博格丹诺维奇讲的，他是一个真正的，你知道的电影学者，他跟我讲了这个故事，因为他和奥逊·威尔斯关系很铁。而且，你知道，奥逊说，你知道，我真的搞不定，你知道，舞台调度，那种东西。托兰德说，哦，周末过来吧，我们来，你知道，你不觉得很棒吗
with the masters when they don't put any kind of pretense. And they're just, I'm one of you guys. Yeah. I love that. And Toland, you know, said, you know, you're the guy, I want to do what you do your vision. You know, how old was he when he made that? Was he 24 in his twenties, I think? Wow. Something like that. And so Wells is in there. And he's, and it was in the days when everybody wore suits and ties and shit, you know, work. And he said, now with the lighting, I want it to come like this, you know, to the gaffer and stuff. And the gaffer goes up to, he says, Mr. Wells, you know, that's really Mr. Toland's job. And Greg Toland overheard that. And he just made a big speech of the whole cast and crew. This is your director, you know,
面对大师们时，他们没有任何做作的姿态。他们只是，我是你们中的一员。对。我太喜欢这个了。托兰德，你知道，他说，你才是那个人，我想做你所做的事，你的愿景。你知道，他拍那部电影时多大？他24岁，二十多岁吧，我想？哇。差不多吧。所以威尔斯进去了。而且，那是每个人都穿着西装打领带的年代，你知道，要工作。他说，现在关于灯光，我希望它是这样的，你知道，对灯光师（gaffer）之类的人说。然后灯光师走过去对他说，威尔斯先生，你知道，那是托兰德先生的工作。而格雷格·托兰德无意中听到了。于是他对全体演员和剧组发表了一大通演讲。这是你们的导演，你知道，
do what he says. He has a vision, you know, do whatever you want or, you know, wow. Gosh, what a movie that is. What a great movie. And I think, I think that what you were kind of saying, like that idea that you have to have, I remember one, some guy telling me a long time ago, acting teacher years ago, like, art is ultimately absent of ego. Like you have to be totally willing and be totally open. If you want to do something great and create something great, you got to get over your own, whatever your shit is and let all that go and be open to the process. Right? Yeah. This is, this is one of the craziest things. I'm a huge sci-fi fan and my husband, Scotty, is to, but you're not going to believe this. One of my favorite movies of all time is Tron.
听他的指挥。他有愿景，你知道，你们想怎么拍就怎么拍，或者，你知道，哇。天哪，那是一部什么样的电影啊。多棒的电影。而且我觉得，我觉得你刚才说的那种意思，就像那种你必须拥有的理念，我记得很久以前，某个家伙，一个老派的表演老师跟我说过，艺术最终是无我的。就像你必须完全愿意并且完全敞开心扉。如果你想做点伟大的事并创造出伟大的作品，你必须放下你自己的，不管你有什么破毛病，然后让这一切随风而去，对创作过程保持开放的心态。对吧？对。这是，这是最疯狂的事情之一。我是一个巨大的科幻迷，我丈夫斯科蒂也是，但你绝对不会相信。我这辈子最喜欢的电影之一就是《电子世界争霸战》。
And he's wearing your shirt right now. That's your character. That's you. What are the odds? Man, Tron, what a big deal that was when it came out. With, with all the, again, all the years that you've been doing this, has the audience that you have been acting for internally, has that changed? Are you conscious of who you're doing your performance for? Cause like sometimes for, and you guys will and Shawn, you should answer this too. Like, do you guys act for the cameraman? Do you act for the director? Do you act for the other actor that you're in the scene with? Do you act for the people that are eventually going to see this? Do you act for yourself when you're eventually going to watch it? Are you, are you even aware of, of that? Interesting. Yeah. I mean,
他现在身上穿的就是你的衬衫。那是你的角色。那就是你。几率有多大？伙计，《电子世界争霸战》，当年上映的时候反响多大啊。伴随着，伴随着，再次提到，这么多年你一直在从事这份工作，你在内心演戏所面对的观众，这有变吗？你会意识到你是在为谁进行表演吗？因为有时候，为了，你们俩——威尔和肖恩，你们也应该回答一下——你们是在为摄像师演戏吗？你们是在为导演演戏吗？你们是在为和你演对手戏的另一个演员演戏吗？你们是在为最终会看到这部电影的人演戏吗？你们是在为将来自己观看时的自己演戏吗？你们甚至会意识到，
I think it's for myself and the director, basically. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You know, he was, you know, I always liked to really, you know, very rarely when I don't, you know, put the, you know, I like to empower the director to have power over me. You do like that. I like, I like that. And, you know, unless I'm getting, you know, some messages from the big director in the sky, I try to, you know, do with the director, you know, cause he can take me away from myself and my own. Yeah. So you'll let the director push you and pull you into places that maybe you weren't even planning on going in the scene and you're just putting trust in the editing room. They're going to weed out all the crap that sucks. Well, that's, you know, the editing, that's the thing. You know,
这一点吗？有趣。对。我的意思是，我觉得这是为了我自己和导演，基本上是这样。对。对。对。你知道，他，你知道，我总是喜欢真正地，你知道，极少数情况下我不会，你知道，把，你知道，我喜欢赋予导演掌控我的权力。你确实喜欢这样。我喜欢，我喜欢那样。而且，你知道，除非我收到来自天上大导演的某种信息，否则我尽量，你知道，听从导演的安排，你知道，因为他能把我从自我和我的固执中拉出来。对。所以你会让导演推着你、拉着你进入那些你甚至没打算在场景中涉足的地方，然后你只是把信任交给剪辑室。他们会把所有糟糕的垃圾都剪掉。好吧，这就是，你知道，剪辑，就是那回事。你知道，
one of my favorite directors to work with, Bo did his first movie, I did his last movie, was Hal Ashby. Oh, yeah. Who was, came from editing, you know, it's interesting where the directors come from, you know. Yeah. And editing, man. I mean, God, well, you must edit that. Yeah. I'd love that part of it. Yeah. That, cause, so I'd like to give the director, you know, it's like photography, I like to bracket my performances, you know, do too much, you know, one in the pocket, what I'm thinking, what he's thinking, and then do something, you know, on either side. Only for the front row. Yeah. Because, you know, in the editing, you don't know what you're going to be cause you always shoot out of sequence. Right. But you, that's putting a lot of trust
我最喜欢的合作导演之一，拍过他第一部电影，我也拍了他最后一部电影，那就是哈尔·阿什比（Hal Ashby）。哦，对。他曾，他是从剪辑师出身的，你知道，导演们出身于哪里挺有意思的。对。而且剪辑，伙计。我的意思是，天哪，好吧，你一定得剪辑那个。对。我喜欢那部分。对。那个，所以我喜欢给导演，你知道，就像摄影一样，我喜欢给我的表演设定“包围曝光”，你知道，演过头一点，你知道，一个在情绪里的，我所想的，他所想的，然后再做一些，你知道，两个极端方向的尝试。只为前排观众。对。因为，你知道，在剪辑的时候，你不知道最终会变成什么样，因为你们总是跳拍。没错。但你，这需要付出极大的信任
in the editor and the director to make sure they don't crank and stuff. Yeah, but you gotta do that. Don't you think, man, if you, if you're holding back, man, I mean, I just thought of a fun director story, you might get a kick out of that. So Coppola and Tucker. Yeah. Our second week, we are first week, we're just kind of getting to know each other. And the second week, he gets the cast and crew together and he says, all right, now this week, we're going to shoot the whole movie on this little video camera of Vittorio Storaro. He'll be using this little wheelchair. That'll be our dolly. And you costume people, you know, the little, look at those curtains. They would make good wedding dress and you actors know your lines as best you can. Cause we're only
交给剪辑师和导演，确保他们不会乱剪一气。对，但你必须这么做。你不觉得吗，伙计，如果你，如果你有所保留，伙计，我的意思是，我刚想到一个有趣的导演故事，你可能会觉得很有意思。所以是科波拉和塔克（Tucker）。对。我们的第二周，我们第一周还在互相了解。到了第二周，他把演员和剧组召集起来，他说，好吧，现在这周，我们要用维托里奥·斯托拉罗（Vittorio Storaro）这台小型摄像机把整部电影拍下来。他会用这个小轮椅。那将是我们的轨道车。你们服装部门，你知道，那个小，看那些窗帘。它们可以做成很好的婚纱，演员们尽可能熟悉台词。因为我们只会
going to do each scene one time. Wow. And we're going to do it in sequence. It was kind of like, you know, the little rascals are getting, you know, let's make a movie. Come on. Yeah. And he's shooting this whole thing. Now, what we didn't know is to and from work, he's editing all of this stuff. And at the end of that week, he gives us each a cassette of the movie. He says, now we've already done the movie. Here's the movie. And now we're just going to polish it up. Wow. And then as we did the movie, he replaced those. Wow. Practice scenes with the real scenes. And even before that, he had a storyboard and he shot the storyboard like the movie, like, you know, two hours. So the movie was always in existence. Isn't that wild? Yeah. So he got to
把每个场景拍一次。哇。而且我们要按顺序拍。这有点像，你知道，“小捣蛋”们聚在一起，来吧，我们拍个电影吧。来吧。对。而且他把整部电影都拍了下来。现在，我们不知道的是，他在上下班的路上，一直在剪辑所有这些素材。在那周末结束时，他给了我们每人一盒电影的磁带。他说，现在我们已经拍完这部电影了。这就是电影。现在我们只需要把它润色一下。哇。然后在我们拍摄电影的过程中，他用真正的场景替换了那些。哇。练习场景。甚至在此之前，他有一个分镜头脚本，他就像拍电影一样按照分镜头脚本拍摄，你知道，拍了两个小时。所以这部电影一直都是现成的。这难道不是很疯狂吗？对。所以他能够
do like a version of the movie, like the, like the storyboard or pre-vis with all the actors. Yeah. And for an actor, because you're always shooting out a sequence to have that linear version of it that you could refer to. Yeah, that's really cool. It was really fascinating. Do you think he was doing it to help you guys out or was it to help himself out? No, no, because he, if you remember that movie, it had all these low tech, it was quite advanced with all its technical low tech kind of stuff that he specialized in. Yeah. You know, like the Dracula movie with Gary Oldman was so great that way, you know. Oh, yeah. And so Francis is, well, he's doing that. He's in the kid mode. You know, we're just playing around. Come on. Now, you know,
拍出电影的一个版本，就像分镜头脚本或预可视化（pre-vis）一样，带着所有的演员。对。而且对于演员来说，因为你总是不按顺序拍摄，能有一个可以参考的线性版本。对，这真的很酷。这真的太迷人了。你觉得他这么做是为了帮你们，还是为了帮他自己？不，不，因为他，如果你还记得那部电影，它有所有这些低技术的，它的技术相当先进，有着他所擅长的各种低技术质感的东西。对。你知道，就像加里·奥德曼演的那部《吸血鬼》那样，棒极了，你知道。哦，对。所以弗朗西斯，好吧，他在扮演孩子的角色。你知道，我们只是在玩。来吧。现在，你知道，
do this. And it was, you know, relaxed and fun. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It was a wild method. What a master he is. I think he's doing another movie right now. Is he? I think so. Oh, God. I lost touch with him. What do you have coming up, Jeff, that you're excited about? Well, I've got this TV show called The Old Man, FX Hulu, and we started it years ago, and then I got terribly sick, and we stopped for two years. Whoa. And then we went back and finished the thing. You went, you did go back and finish it? We went back and finished the season, and it was like we had a long weekend,
做这个。而且，你知道，很放松，很好玩。对。对。对。这真是一个疯狂的方法。他真是一位大师。我觉得他现在正在拍另一部电影。是吗？我想是的。哦，天哪。我和他失去联系了。杰夫，你接下来有什么让你兴奋的项目吗？好吧，我有这个叫《老头》（The Old Man）的电视剧，在FX和Hulu上播，我们几年前就开始了，然后我生了场大病，我们停了两两年。哇。然后我们回去把这事完成了。你们回去把这部剧拍完了？我们回去拍完了整季，感觉就像我们度了个漫长的周末，
and I had this weird dream, man. Hey, listen, you seem, yeah, how are you feeling? How are you doing, man? You look great. I got to say, you sure do. You look very good. I'm feeling great. Yeah. You know, those tough times, you know, it's like what you were saying, Will, about, you know, these tough times, man. Yeah. These tough times, there are opportunities to teach us things that we can't learn without them, you know. Yeah. And let's, you know, let's do some trim tab and let's influence as much as we can to make a beautiful movie, you know, make, you know, work together to make the cool thing, man. Yeah. Dude, I love that. I love that analogy too. I like that idea that we're kind of like, life is like,
而且我做了一个奇怪的梦，伙计。嘿，听着，你看起来，是的，你感觉怎么样？你最近怎么样，伙计？你看起来气色真好。我得说，你确实如此。你看上去状态极佳。我感觉好极了。对。你知道，那些艰难的时刻，你知道，就像你刚才说的，威尔，关于，你知道，这些艰难的时刻，伙计。对。这些艰难的时刻，它们是教会我们一些如果没有它们我们就无法学到的事情的契机，你知道。对。让我们，你知道，让我们做一点微调片（trim tab），让我们尽可能多地发挥影响力，去拍一部美丽的电影，你知道，去创作，你知道，齐心协力去创造酷炫的东西，伙计。对。老兄，我太喜欢这个了。我也很喜欢这个比喻。我喜欢那种我们仿佛身处其中的想法，生活就像是，
you were saying like, it's really cool what we get to do. If you really think about it, it's really cool what we get to do just to be alive and to have these lives. That's right. And this is the big, all of us, this is the big movie that we get to do. For sure, every day. Making movies is such a great metaphor for how we can make this a beautiful world, you know, get all these people, they have all different political, you know, outlooks and different personalities. Some are gloomy, you know, some actors only want to, you know, call me by my character, you know, all kinds of different versions, but everybody's trying to make a beautiful movie. Yeah, I love that. Touches us. I love that.
你刚才说的，我们能做的事真的很酷。如果你仔细想想，仅仅是活着并拥有这些人生，我们所能做的事就真的很酷。没错。这就是宏大的，我们所有人，这就是我们能经历的宏大电影。当然，每一天都是。拍电影是关于我们如何能把这个世界变得更美好的绝佳隐喻，你知道，把所有这些人聚在一起，他们有着截然不同的政治，你知道，观点和不同的个性。有些人很忧郁，你知道，有些演员只想，你知道，用我的角色名来叫我，你知道，有各种各样不同的版本，但每个人都在努力拍一部美丽的电影。对，我喜欢这个。触动我们心灵。我喜欢这个。
That's what, that's what the world ought to be doing. Right. Somehow, you know, all work together, all these, all these specialists, you know, all these masters, they get together to pull this magic trick off. One-time magic trick. Yeah. Yeah. It's really so wild. I love it because I feel like, Jeff, that you're still in love with the magic of it, not so much the details or the tech, you know, all the technical. You really, you live in the magic. That's where it is for you. And I get that sense from you, man, which I really love. It's the thing you can't explain or write down or diagram. It's that paradox thing, right, Sean? It's both, right, Sean? It's like, you're into the details and you're, and then you're into the magic. I mean,
这才是世界应该做的事情。不知怎么的，你知道，大家一起努力，所有这些，所有这些专家，你知道，所有这些大师，他们聚在一起完成了这个魔术。一次性的魔术。对。对。这真的太疯狂了。我很喜欢它，因为我觉得，杰夫，你依然深爱着它的魔术本身，而不是太在意那些细节或技术，你知道，所有那些技术性的东西。你真的生活在魔术里。那才是对你而言最重要的地方。我从你身上感受到了这一点，伙计，我真的很喜欢。那是你无法解释、写下或绘制图表的东西。那是悖论，对吧，肖恩？两者兼有，对吧，肖恩？就像，你既沉迷于细节，而你，然后你又沉迷于魔术。我的意思是，
it's all going on at the same time, man. It's a paradox, isn't it? You're always living in the present. Yeah. That's the gig kind of, that's what I try to do. So I will tell you this, one of the other things. So I kind of, we've taken up too much of your time, but I wanted to point out that, you know, I already pointed out that you and Jason started and you're both child actors, but you and Jason also have had some voiceover experience in the world. And there was a time, Jeff, for many years when the Hyundai Motor Company had a real solid voice and had a guy who had a lot of gravitas over and then they decided that they wanted to do something light. They wanted to go light. And I wasn't available. A little bit more economical, a little bit more sensible.
这一切都在同时发生，老兄。这是一个悖论，不是吗？你总是活在当下。是的。这有点像是我的工作，这也是我一直在努力做的。所以我要告诉你这件事，另一件事。所以我想，我们占用了你太多时间，但我想指出的是，你知道，我已经指出过你和杰森是一起出道的，你们俩都是童星，但你和杰森在配音界也有过一些经验。曾经有一段时间，杰夫，很多年里，现代汽车公司有一个非常坚定的声音，有一个很有威严的配音员，然后他们决定想做一些轻松的事情。他们想走轻松路线。而我当时没空。稍微经济一点，稍微明智一点。
Here's why it was. I think you were nominated for an Oscar and Hyundai had bought a bunch of ad time during the Oscars. And so they couldn't have you being the voice of one of the ads because it would, it would screw up the sort of unbiased whatever it was. So some sort of legal thing. So I had to do one of those spots. Yeah, I think that's what it was. Yeah. Oh, I totally forgot about that. Willie, that's hilarious. Yeah. Well, listen, we're not, it's not professional grade, nor is it sorry, not sorry. You know, Will's, Will's got some very big campaigns, Jeff. Well, you've got a wonderful voice. I'm not, I'm no Jeff Bridges, but you know what I mean? I've got a voice. You've got some good tone there. Wonderful. I'm working on my campaign. I put together a demo
原因其实是这样的。我想你当时获得了奥斯卡提名，而现代汽车在奥斯卡颁奖典礼期间买了一堆广告时段。所以他们不能让你成为其中一个广告的配音，因为这会打破某种中立性，随便什么吧。所以这牵涉到某种法律问题。所以我不得不去录其中一个广告。是的，我想就是这样。哦，我完全把这事忘了。威利，太搞笑了。好吧，听着，我们这水平可算不上专业级，也不是什么“抱歉，但我没错”。你知道，威尔，威尔有很多非常大的广告活动，杰夫。好吧，你的声音真棒。我可不是杰夫·布里吉斯，但你知道我的意思吗？我确实有副好嗓子。你那里的音质挺好的。太棒了。我正在为我的广告活动做准备，我录了一段试音
tape. So many murdering a cat. What's going on? I feel like your voice, you remind me of it. You know, I'm thinking that this is kind of, I promoted a few of my weirder movies on this show, but another weird one, the amateurs. And when you were doing that voice show, you reminded me of Joey Pantz. Do you know him? Oh yeah. I love Joey Pantz. And he was playing a character called some idiot and he was, he had that voice. Exactly. And Ted dancing, you guys worked with Ted, and even you guys worked with Ted. Yes, don't know if he's worked with them, but I do like him a lot. He's great. He's great. He's wonderful. Good. Jeff, I'll say this, man, but I'm going to let you, we're going to let you go because you've been so generous with your time and kind. But I, you know,
磁带。简直就像在虐猫。怎么回事？我觉得你的声音，你让我想起了它。你知道我在想，这有点像，我在这档节目里宣传过一些我比较怪异的电影，但还有一部怪异的，那就是《业余爱好者》。当你在做那个配音秀的时候，你让我想起了乔伊·潘茨。你认识他吗？哦，对。我很喜欢乔伊·潘茨。他当时在扮演一个叫某某笨蛋的角色，他就是那种声音。完全是这样。还有特德·丹森，你们和特德合作过，甚至你们都和特德合作过。是的，不知道他有没有和他们合作过，但我真的很喜欢他。他太棒了。他太棒了。他真了不起。太好了。杰夫，我想说的是，老兄，但我要放你，我们要让你走了，因为你对我们太慷慨、太友好了。但我，你知道，
we're big fans. I think we speak for a lot of people always have been, man, and really, really love your energy and really love what you do. And kind of like your co-star, John Goodman, I've said this to the boys before, you're, you're in that same category for me as John Goodman. You guys have never, never phoned it in, never turned into bad performance ever, no matter what the picture is, you guys are always there, man. And it is such an honor and a treat. And I just think you're the best, Uncle Jeff. And you give us all a good name. Uncle Jeff. Thank you, man. Great hanging with you guys. You too, buddy. Say hi to Beau, please. Yeah, please send our love to Beau. I'm your father, Beau. All of our dad. Lots of love, guys. All right, buddy. You too, man.
我们是你的超级粉丝。我想我们代表了很多人，一直都是，老兄，真的非常喜欢你的活力，也非常喜欢你做的事情。就像你的联合主演约翰·古德曼一样，我以前对这几个伙计说过，在我心里，你和约翰·古德曼是同一类人。你们从来没有敷衍过，从来没有过糟糕的表演，不管是什么电影，你们总是全力以赴，老兄。这真的是一种荣幸和款待。我只想说你是最棒的，杰夫叔叔。你给我们大家都长脸了。杰夫叔叔。谢谢你，老兄。和你在一起玩得很开心。你也是，伙计。代我向博问好，好吗？是的，请把我们的爱意带给博。我是你的父亲，博。我们共同的爸爸。送上满满的爱，伙计们。好的，伙计。你也是，老兄。
See you later. Bye, Jeff. How do you know him, Will? Will, how are you? What, what, how do you? Uncle Jeff. My buddy, Uncle Jeff. You don't know Jeff Bridges. What the hell is going on? Because cool guys hang together, dude. No, I don't think so. When you're cool, you hang with other cool people. They're like a chat room, cool guys hang out in. It's for guys who are handsome with good voices. We're in a special... Oh, I haven't gotten an invitation. Jesus Christ. I swear to God. I am looking in the mail every day. Is somebody drowning a weasel? What's going on? Yeah, what a good, that dude just makes me feel good. He's the greatest. So when Sean and I were doing this show years ago, the Millers, and Beau was playing my dad on the show, and I went to New York and I
回头见。再见，杰夫。你怎么认识他的，威尔？威尔，你好吗？什么，什么，你怎么？杰夫叔叔。我的好哥们，杰夫叔叔。你根本不认识杰夫·布里吉斯。到底是怎么回事？因为酷的人总是混在一起，老兄。不，我不这么认为。当你够酷的时候，你就会和其它酷的人交往。他们就像一个聊天室，酷的人都在里面混。这是专为那些长相帅气、声音好听的男人准备的。我们身处一个特别的……哦，我还没收到邀请呢。天哪。我发誓。我每天都在查看信箱。有人在淹死一只黄鼠狼吗？怎么回事？是的，多么美好的一件事，那家伙就是能让我感觉良好。他太棒了。所以当肖恩和我几年前在做这个节目《米勒一家》时，博在剧里扮演我的爸爸，我去了纽约，然后我
ran into Jeff. We were doing the Today Show, and he was like, hey, man, I'm kind of like your uncle. And I was like, all right. And then we had to do these photos backstage. He's like, let's just fuck around. And I was like, I love that he has that fuck around in him. Yeah, he's just so easy going. Yeah, he really got a great positive vibe. And so we just started chatting and I just immediately was... And I've always been a massive fan. I remember watching all of his movies, and he just has this effect. But I remember being in my early 20s and seeing in quick succession, seeing Fisher King, which I thought that character was so interesting. And I think about that character more than I probably should. His character, who was this big DJ, and he gets offered a
遇到了杰夫。我们当时正在做《今日秀》，他就说：“嘿，老兄，我有点像你的叔叔。”我当时想：“好吧。”然后我们得在后台拍这些照片。他说：“我们随便玩玩吧。”我当时就想，我太喜欢他这种随性玩闹的性格了。是的，他就是那么随和。是的，他真的有一种很棒的积极能量。于是我们开始聊天，我立刻就……我一直都是他的超级粉丝。我记得我看过他的所有电影，他总是有这种影响力。但我记得在我20多岁的时候，接连看了《奇幻城市》，我当时觉得那个角色太有趣了。我回想起那个角色的次数可能比我应该想的还要多。他的角色，是一个大电台DJ，然后有人提供给他一个
sitcom and he turns it down. Remember that thing? He's kind of like a shock jock. And he ends up, his life gets turned upside down by this insane Robin Williams character. So there's that. And then he did that movie Fearless. I just remember you were talking about the crashing. But for me, it wasn't the crashing. It was this idea. You're seeing this metamorphosis again of a guy who has this event happen and he completely changes his outlook and he lets go. And it really hit me. It was very profound to me. It really spoke to me, man. And then, of course, Big Lebowski and everything. But I've always felt connected to that dude. Yeah, he's just such good energy. And he's been so consistent and genuine and sincere,
情景喜剧，但他拒绝了。还记得那件事吗？他有点像那种语出惊人的电台主持人。到最后，他的生活被这个疯狂的罗宾·威廉姆斯的角色搞得天翻地覆。所以这就是其中之一。然后他拍了那部电影《无畏》。我只记得你当时在谈论坠机事件。但对我来说，不是坠机事件，而是这种理念。你再次看到一个经历过这种事件并彻底改变了人生观、学会放手的男人的蜕变。这真的触动了我。对我来说非常深刻。它真的对我有触动，老兄。然后，当然还有《谋杀绿脚趾》以及其他一切。但我一直觉得自己和那个家伙很有共鸣。是的，他身上有那么好的能量。而且他一直都那么稳定、真实、诚恳，
it seems, for years and years. Yeah, you hit it, Will, when you said he, no matter what movie he's in, because we've all kind of been like, I don't know if the script is so great or the script is amazing or whatever it is. It doesn't matter. He goes, he does it 100% all the time, every single role. Here's the other thing. Don't you guys think it's weird that Scottie had on Jeff Bridges' T-shirt? Not really. Not really. Because it could have just been like one of like five things. It could have been Star Trek, Star Wars, Tron, you know what I mean? Or just I love Chin Chin short. Or I love Chin Chin or Koi. But that's crazy that he had the T-shirt on
似乎很多年都是这样。是的，你说得对，威尔，当你谈到他时，无论他演的是什么电影，因为我们所有人其实都经历过这种情况，那就是“我不知道这个剧本到底好不好，或者剧本是不是棒极了，诸如此类”。这都无所谓。他会说，他每次都会百分之百地投入，每一个角色都是如此。还有一件事。你们不觉得斯科蒂穿着杰夫·布里吉斯的T恤很奇怪吗？不怎么觉得。不怎么觉得。因为那可能只是大概五种东西之一。可能是《星际迷航》、《星球大战》、《创：战纪》，你知道我的意思吗？或者只是“我爱锦锦短裤”。或者“我爱锦锦”或者“锦鲤”。但穿着那件T恤真是太疯狂了
that from Tron and we're talking to Jeff Bridges. Do you guys have a, do you have a license plate holder that says, follow me to Koi? Do you? I'm not, I'm not flirting. I'm just being Koi. Listener Koi is a fusion restaurant here on Restaurant Well, according to Sean, Sean, what is it? It's a seafood restaurant, right? You can't not see food there. No, no, no. Lund John Silver's is a seafood restaurant. He's a fucking fusion Japanese restaurant. The fuck are you, what? Well, go there in about a half hour. You'll see me. But wait, also, so the, so the ranch that he lived on, he said there's no more like cows or horse or anything. Do you think there was
来自《创：战纪》，而我们现在正和杰夫·布里吉斯谈话。你们有没有那种车牌框，上面写着“跟着我到锦鲤餐厅”？有吗？我不是在调情。我只是在“装害羞（锦鲤的双关）”。听众朋友们，“锦鲤”是我们这里的一家融合餐厅。好吧，根据肖恩的说法，肖恩，那是什么？是一家海鲜餐厅，对吧？你在那里不可能看不到海鲜。不，不，不。朗·约翰·西尔弗（Long John Silver's）是一家海鲜餐厅。他妈的是一家融合日本料理餐厅。你他妈的在说什么？好吧，大约半小时后去那里。你会看到我的。但等等，还有，他住过的那个农场，他说那里再也没有牛、马或其他什么东西了。你觉得那里
ever once any bison? SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Grant Terry. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《SmartLess》由罗布·阿姆朱夫、贝内特·巴拉科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里100%有机手工制作。《SmartLess》。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。